Ich hab auf Rekord gedrückt.
Hallo.
Ja, hallo, willkommen. Willkommen zu Mobile Max Nummer, na, wer weiß es auswendig, 16. Dennis. Hervorragend.
Großartig. Kann ich nach vorne?
Ja, er passt auf. Ich hatte Zweifel, aber er ist einfach dabei.
Im Gegensatz zu mir, ich wusste jetzt nicht, welchen Nummer wir sind.
Ja, du warst durcheinander, warst mit dem Fuß.
Aber ich weiß, wir sitzen heute mal wieder in einem Raum.
Mit ohnebekloppte Latenz.
Jetzt kann ich euch endlich wieder ordentlich dazwischen quatschen.
Das war vielleicht scheiße. Also ich weiß auch nicht, was da passiert ist bei der letzten Aufnahme. Es war ein Drama. Irgendwie waren die Aufnahmen unterschiedlich lang, dann habe ich das irgendwie gestretched. Offensichtlich war die Verbindung von meinem Skype zu Dennis Skype so, dass die Latenz permanent variiert hat. Und egal, wie ich das dann in der Timeline hin und her geschoben habe, das hat dann irgendwie mal gepasst und mal nicht gepasst.
Das hat aber nichts mit Skype zu tun, weil ich meine, mit Skype war das ja alles. Wir konnten uns ja alle super unterhalten. Das ist ja nicht so, als ob wir dann eine massive Pause gehabt hätten. Das muss ja in den Aufnahmen gewesen sein.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab da fünf Stunden irgendwie hin und her geschoben und das immer wieder an 20 Stellen getestet und dann wieder festgestellt, dass es an anderen Stellen völlig aus dem Leim ging. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab jetzt auch erstmal keinen Bock mehr darüber nachzudenken, was das Problem war. Auf jeden Fall hätten wir mal häufiger in die Hände klatschen müssen.
Ich kann ja jetzt mal in die Hände klatschen.
Du kannst ja mal in die Hände klatschen. 3, 2, 1. Na das wird mal echt synchron.
Jitter?
Das war einfach nur das Klatschen in die Hände klatschen.
Du bist ja auch so ein traditioneller Typ.
Ein traditioneller Klatscher.
Ja, du stehst so oft. Klatschst du auch im Flugzeug? Bei der Landung?
Nee, da hab ich zu viel Angst. Nein. Das ist so was, was ich nicht verstehe. Da kann man auch beim Busfahrer klatschen.
Bei einem Busfahrer, wenn er erfolgreich die Haltestelle angefahren hat. So ist die Endhaltestelle.
Also ich meine, das erwartet man. Dafür bezahlt man den Menschen.
Das wäre mal ein guter Hack. Da gibt es doch diese supergeile Truppe, Improve Everywhere. Kennst du die?
Ja.
Die einfach immer diese geilen Aktionen bringen, wie neulich zum Beispiel, als sie alle in die, wie heißt diese Hauptstation da, die Warnstation?
Central Station.
Central Station in New York war das, ne?
Genau.
Und wo sie dann alle so auf Kommando gefriest sind.
Das war großartig.
Herrlich, ne? So eine Nummer. Und das machst du dann im Bus?
Einfach alle aufstehen?
Die gesamte Besatzung? Nein, einfach alle im Bus klatschen.
Bitte bleiben Sie noch sitzen, bis wir unsere endgültige Halteposition erweist haben.
Damit könnte man eine Menge beitragen, um die Laune von Berliner Busfahrern.
Noch weiter zu reduzieren.
Freuen sich dann vielleicht.
Nein, Berliner nicht.
Na wie auch immer.
Ich glaube, die holen dann sofort einen Bombenkommando oder sowas.
Ja, willkommen hier. Also, naja, Bus ist ja der andere Podcast. Also reden wir hier nicht über Busse, sondern wir reden hier über, ja, worüber reden wir denn diesmal? Also, worüber auf jeden Fall reden muss, ist... Mäuse und Moneten. Mäuse und Moneten, pinke, pinke, Cash, Klingeling, Schotter.
Hat's gemacht, oder?
Oh ja, und wie? Apple hat richtig eingefahren und interessanterweise sind sie ja mittlerweile auch in der Lage, in diesem normalerweise recht mäßig nachgefragten Quarter, wie heißt das bei ihnen? Das ist dann Quarter 4, ne? Genau, bei Apple geht's jetzt mit 2009 schon ein bisschen früher los. Schaffen sie es halt auch ordentlich einzufahren. Ich hab mir hier mal so ein paar Zahlen notiert und das ist alles wahnsinnig impressive. Zum Beispiel haben sie, wir müssen mal eure Twitter leiser machen, aber sie haben 17% Umsatz zugelegt, das klingt alles noch nicht so toll. Und was mich auch gewundert hat, ist, dass ihre durchschnittliche Marge gestiegen ist. Ihr erinnert euch, dass sie das letzte Mal noch groß gewarnt haben, dass ihre Marge sinken würde?
Genau, ist nicht passiert.
Und keiner wusste, worauf sich das bezieht? Und ich meinte, es wären die iPods. Und dann kamen die iPods und irgendwie war nicht so richtig ersichtlich, warum das jetzt ausgerechnet zur gesunkenen Marge beitragen soll. Und dann meinten ja alle vielleicht die Macbooks, aber die sind ja eigentlich in einem anderen Quartal. Völlig unklar.
Also techniker Mutmaß, dass sie vielleicht das Blu-ray einführen wollten. Wobei ich das auch nicht für ganz schlüssig halte.
Ich hab gelesen, dass die Produktion der neuen Gehäuse heilt, weil die vorproduziert werden mussten.
Das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, aber offensichtlich hat das dann nicht so reingeschlagen. Also, aber die Marge bezieht sich doch auf ein Gerät. Die Marge ist doch das, was du auf ein Gerät ausgibst und im Vergleich zu dem, was du dafür einnimmst. Das heißt, die Gesamtkosten, die jetzt...
Die Differenz zwischen Umsatz und...
Genau, aber pro Gerät. Egal, wann du es jetzt baust und verkaufst. Es bleibt unklar. Auf jeden Fall ist sie nicht besonders gesunken, sondern sie liegt immer noch bei atemberaubenden 34,7 Prozent. 34,7 Prozent, das ist der Schnitt an den Büchsen. Wenn du da 1000 Euro reinträgst, die könnten den locker mal ein Drittel billiger machen. Was?
Die könnten also alles locker ein Drittel billiger machen.
Nö, das könnten sie nicht, weil sie geben ja auch die Kohle wieder aus.
Nee, das ist ja 24 Milliarden Dollar rumliegen. In bar.
Na gut, die brauchen sie aber vielleicht, falls mal harten Zeit kommt. Was schon, so Finanzkrise und so, wenn man keine Kredite mehr kriegt und mal was kaufen muss.
Oder um Microsoft zu retten.
Ach du meinst irgendwie bei der nächsten D-Bell-App-Meeting.
Das hat mich jetzt überzeugt. Windows Azure, das deutet doch darauf hin, dass diesmal nicht die Marketing-Abteilung sich einen Namen und aus dem Nichts ausgedacht hat.
Du lenkst schon wieder ab.
Stimmt.
Also, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall haben sie ordentlich Kohle eingefahren. Und sie verdienen halt 340, 70, 347 Euro von den 1000, die du da lässt. Das ist eine Menge. Das ist eine Menge Holz.
Ja, gerade im IT-Bereich.
So, wie hat sich denn das jetzt ausgewirkt? Also, soll ich mal ein paar Zahlen runterrasseln? Ihr habt euch das bestimmt wieder nicht notiert. Ich hab mich mal richtig hingesetzt und hab mir das mal alles so auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, weil ich fand das doch ganz schön beeindruckend. Achso, übrigens für diese Low-Margin-Guidances, doch, da stimmt, da hab ich mir notiert. Sie meinten, dass tatsächlich die Unibody-Macbooks dafür, sozusagen, diese Low-Margin-Guidance sei, tatsächlich bezog sich auf die Unibody-Macbooks.
Das heißt, dass die Herstellung dieser Unibodies erstmal ein bisschen teurer ist, weswegen die Marge runtergeht, aber wahrscheinlich auf lange Sicht, weil sie einen dicken Vertrag haben, lohnt sich dann noch.
Ich dachte, das bezieht sich auf das letzte Quartal. Außerdem heißt es noch, September's iPod Refresh also played a role in the Guidance. Also, es ist sowohl die iPods als auch die Macbooks. Aber ist ja nicht passiert, also von daher, das verstehe ich nicht. Vielleicht versteht das ja einer mehr als...
Vielleicht ist es halt immer so, wenn die erstmal auf ein neues Gehäuse umschalten, am Anfang.
Immer so auf ein neues Gehäuse. Was haben die das letzte Mal auf ein neues Gehäuse umgeschaltet? Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall haben sie 21% mehr Macs verkauft. Das sind jetzt 2,6 Millionen pro Quartal.
Also 10 Millionen im Jahr.
Das ist in der Tat die Zahl, die sie jetzt angesteuert haben. Das heißt, das ist jetzt das fiskalische Jahr, 10 Millionen.
Wenn es seit Anfang 2006 Intel Macs gibt, dann haben wir jetzt ca. 25, vielleicht knapp weniger, Intel Macs schon unterwegs.
25 Millionen?
Wir haben am Anfang nicht ganz so viele Intel Macs verkauft. Da waren ja noch ein bisschen Power-PCs verkauft. Und vielleicht auch noch nicht ganz so viele wie jetzt. Also aber dieses Jahr 10 Millionen, letztes Jahr 10 Millionen und 2006 halt auch noch mal 5.
Weiß ich nicht genau, ob ich jetzt nicht zusammengerechnet, aber auf jeden Fall die Mehrheit aller Macs, die jetzt in Betrieb sind, sind Intel Macs. Das kann man sicher festhalten. Sie haben in Amerika 16% zugelegt, sie haben in Europa 22% zugelegt und in Japan 8% zugelegt. Mit anderen Worten, Europa ist der Markt, wo sie derzeit am heftigsten zuschlagen.
Bestimmt nicht in Deutschland, oder? In Deutschland, genau, bestimmt können wir noch die Mediamarkt-Kisten besser weg.
Mediamarkt, die haben doch auch...
Apple Store.
Da fällt da 30 Zoller da so rum.
Ich war da am Alex.
Ach, was jetzt da?
Horrible, es ist wirklich schlimm.
Naja, und vor allem, es gibt ja immer diese alte Mär mit dem Unit-Market-Share, mit dem Dollar-Market-Share. Das haben sie ja diesmal auch mal hochoffiziell beleuchtet, weil es diesmal sehr entscheidend war. Und der Dollar-Market-Share bei Notebooks wohlgemerkt, also jetzt nicht bei Desktop, sondern nur bei Notebooks, was aber immerhin zwei Drittel des Geschäfts ausmacht, ist jeder dritte Dollar, der in den USA über den Ladentisch geht, wohlgemerkt Retail, also es sind einige Disclaimer dabei, es bezieht sich jetzt nur auf Retail, aber das ist ja für den Konsumerbereich nach wie vor wichtig, genau. Und, naja, aber immerhin, also ein Drittel des Marktes, des Geldes, genau. Jeder dritte Dollar geht an Apple.
Ist dann auch ihr eigener Retail rausgenommen, wenn sie Retail rausnehmen?
Nee, nur Retail.
Retail an sich inklusive des Apple Stores. Ich hab sechs Wochen keine Clubmart mehr getrunken.
Und?
Schmeckt schon anders, oder?
Super, man gewöhnt sich dran.
Das sollten die mal als Slogan machen.
Haben die.
Ach denn, das.
Wie auch immer. 8% mehr iPods, finde ich auch bemerkenswert die Zahl, wo auch immer so gemunkelt wird, so iPods und so, das geht ja alles den Bach runter. Nicht die Bohne, mehr iPods verkauft als jemals, in einem Nicht-Weihnachts-Quartal. Also, auch da geht's voran. Und das, obwohl halt noch die iPhones dazukommen.
Nicht wenig, ne?
Nicht wenig, man, die Zahl habt ihr ja sehr ehrlich gelesen.
Ich glaube, 7 Millionen pro Quartal, 6,8 oder so ist?
6,8, 9, 2, 7 Millionen iPhones, 515% Steigerung.
Ja gut, das ist ja halt mehr oder weniger noch eine Produktneuentführung des 3G, das kann man so nicht sehen. Wobei, das MacBook Pro so gesehen ist auch eine Produktneuentführung.
Ja, also das kannst du schon sagen, dass du mehr MacBooks verkauft hast.
Nee, aber das haben die im Jahr nicht noch mal.
Na, in einem Jahr kommt das nächste iPhone raus und was weiß ich, was dann passiert? Weiß da gar ja, ob es dann noch ein paar von den Konkurrenten, die sie jetzt noch auf ihren Vergleichstabellen haben, überhaupt noch auf dem Markt sind.
Ist noch ein Konkurrent da?
Na ja, auf dem Papier schon.
Rimmen nicht mehr?
Doch, Rimmen ist noch einer der wenigen.
Haben sie schon abgehangen?
Na ja, jemanden auf Platz zwei in Verkaufszahlen zu verweisen, ist das eine. Also, so brauchen wir da ja nicht ranzugehen. Aber sie haben jetzt schon mehr verkauft als Rimmen in diesem Quartal, muss man dazu sagen. Sie haben mehr Geld verdient als alle anderen, mit der Ausnahme von Nokia und Samsung. Aber sie haben jetzt schon mehr als ein Drittel des Umsatzes von Nokia. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Sie haben mehr als...
Ja, mit Mobiltelefonen.
Und das mit genau einem Modell, das finde ich ganz lustig.
Genau, mit zwei. Nee, mit einem, stimmt, richtig, mit einem.
Also ich würde sagen, es zählt noch als eins.
Achso, ich bezog mich jetzt auf das alte iPhone. Du hast schon recht, ja, also mit einer Modellfamilie.
Wie viel wurden denn vor dem alten jetzt eigentlich verkauft? Da musst du doch Zahlen geben, insgesamt.
Ja, gab's, waren, glaube ich, so auch so 7 Millionen bisher.
Das heißt, gibt es jetzt ungefähr schon gleich viele alte wie neue iPhones?
Oder was, waren es 7? Ich weiß nicht. Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Ich sag eine andere Zahl. Auf jeden Fall sind sie jetzt nach Geld die Nummer 3. Und sie sind sehr, sehr, sehr knapp hinter Samsung.
So knapp ist es nicht. Was irgendwie 4,6 zu 4,9 oder so. Die waren doch bei 5,8 oder so.
5,8, ich weiß es jetzt nicht mehr genau. Auf jeden Fall ist das nichts, was man nicht noch erreichen könnte. Schön finde ich das, wenn man jetzt mal hochrechnet. Sie haben jetzt 10 Millionen iPhones verkauft dieses Jahr. 10 Millionen wollten sie verkaufen. Haben sie gesagt, dass sie das mal vorhaben. Das haben sie jetzt schon geschafft. Das haben sie ja auch explizit gesagt.
Das ist dieser berühmte Steve Jobs Spruch, den man so, so oder so auslegen kann.
Ja, aber selbst wenn man ihnen sozusagen maximal zum Nachteil auslegt, dass sie 10 Millionen in 2008 und nicht insgesamt verkaufen wollen, das haben sie jetzt erreicht. Sie haben dieses Jahr, in diesem Kalenderjahr, schon 10 Millionen verkauft. Und wenn man jetzt auch das selbe Verhältnis von iPods im dritten, also dritten Kalenderquartal, zum vierten Kalenderquartal anlegt aufs iPhone, also wenn man davon ausgeht, dass dieselbe Zuwachsrate sich beim iPhone jetzt wiederholt wie beim iPod und wie das auch letztes Jahr mit dem iPhone war, dann werden sie locker, also locker, locker 20 Millionen iPhones verkauft haben dieses Jahr.
Bis wann wird das dauern, bis jeder eins hat?
Nicht mehr so lange, aber erinnert ihr euch noch an eine andere ähnliche Zahl, nämlich die Steve Boimer verbreitet hat und meinte, iPhone wäre doch alles total scheiße und würde eh keinen Erfolg haben. Sie würden ja dieses Jahr 20 Millionen Lizenzen von ihrem Windows-Mobile verkaufen.
Haben sie denn nicht geschafft?
Das haben sie noch nicht mal geschafft, sondern sie mussten das nach unten korrigieren auf 18 Millionen. Mit anderen Worten, sie werden Windows-Mobile in Units komplett überholt haben. In einem Jahr.
Was war das Moment, wenn sie 20 Millionen verkauft haben und Apple hat 10 Millionen verkauft?
Nein, Apple hat jetzt schon 10 Millionen verkauft. Sie haben jetzt 7 Millionen verkauft. Normalerweise verkaufen sie im Weihnachtsquartal doppelt so viele wie im Quartal davor. Das wären 7 plus 7 macht 14. 14 plus die 10, die sie schon verkauft haben, würde bedeuten, dass sie 24 Millionen Geräte verkaufen dieses Jahr. Und wenn wir jetzt mal konservativ rangehen und sagen, es sind nur 20, was sie mit Sicherheit schaffen werden. Oder was heißt mit Sicherheit, wo ich einfach wenig Zweifel habe, dass das passieren wird. Dann haben sie sozusagen in diesem Jahr, es ist nicht nur an Platz 3 der Telefonherstellerliste geschafft, sondern sie haben es auch geschafft, rein an Units Windows Mobile zu übertrumpfen.
Aua!
Und die verkaufen an jeden. An jeden. Also es sieht wirklich schlimm aus für alle anderen. Und Motorola und so, wo ich ja schon immer meinte, die werden es nicht mehr lange machen, machen sie den Eindruck, als ob sie es nicht mehr lange machen. Also das ist schon krass. Und vor allem, sie haben jetzt wieder ein super Quartalsergebnis hingelegt, aber das, obwohl sie ja das iPhone auf zwei Jahre hin abschreiben. Das heißt, ein jetzt verkauftes iPhone geht nur zu einem Minimalteil überhaupt in die Quartalsbilanz ein.
Wie geht das voll? Als Verlust rein? Aber nur teilweise als Gewinn?
Ein Achtel. Also jedes iPhone, was verkauft wird jetzt, zieht nur zu einem Achtel in das Quartal, in dem es verkauft wird, ein.
Und bei der ersten Generation war das auch schon so?
Ja.
Das heißt, man kriegt jetzt natürlich aber auch noch den Gewinn von den vorher verkauften iPhones mit rein. Aber da natürlich jetzt damals ja noch nicht so viel verkauft wurde und jetzt mehr, schlägt das jetzt ganz anders ein. Schlägt das erst über die nächsten zwei Jahre ein.
Würden sie das nicht so machen, und hätten sie diese Quartal so abgerechnet, wie sie ihre iPods machen, müssten sie erstens für die Updates Geld machen, aber würde man dann mal schauen, was sie verdient haben, oder verdient hätten. Was sie haben, dann hätten sie 2,4 Milliarden Gewinn gemacht. Zum Vergleich, Microsoft macht 4. Also Apple ist fast da. Also im Weihnachtsquartal, ich weiß nicht, wer sie jetzt noch aufhalten soll.
Also am Weihnachten wirst du da bestimmt voll der Renner.
Was ist das V-Wort gesagt? Die neuen Werbespots? Also den dritten fand ich ein bisschen schwach. Aber wo ich mich nicht satt sehen konnte, ist wirklich dieser Bean-Counter, wo Hodgman, Mr. PC da irgendwie sitzt und das Geld schön verteilt, sehr große Stapel. Da haben sie sich wirklich echt einen geschossen mit diesem Vogel, der ist einfach so dermaßen perfekt. Ja, das find ich unglaublich.
Ich fand ja mit dem V-Word besser.
Was noch dazukommt, ist, dass sie wohl auch extrem viel international verkauft haben. Sie meinen, sie hätten auch eine ganze Menge First-Time-iPhone-Owners, also die Expansion, die weltweite, die schlägt sich hier auf jeden Fall ab.
Das iPhone ist ja auch wahrscheinlich ein starker Multiplayer für Macintosh Computers.
Naja, wenn man jetzt mal sagt, was ist denn die Installed Base von OS X, dann wird es ja noch interessanter. Also nicht nur 10 Millionen Mac OS X-Lizenzen in Form von Hardware neu dazugekommen, sondern das doppelte vielleicht am Ende dieses Jahres noch mal auf dem iPhone, sprich, wo es noch vor zwei Jahren pro Jahr 4 Millionen neue OS X-User gab, hast du halt jetzt 30 mit dem entsprechenden Markt und wenn man sich anschaut, wie der Upstore läuft, der läuft gut. 200 Millionen Downloads, das weiß ich, wie viel Kohle die da jeden Tag machen.
Ich wills auch nicht wissen, wie viel ich da schon ausgegeben hab.
Ja, ich hab da auch schon richtig Kohle gelassen.
Das ist krass, oder?
Ich noch nicht.
Ich hab's nicht zusammengezählt, aber...
Ich bin geizig.
Ja, du bist geizig, aber ich glaube, viele Leute kaufen einfach mal. Wenn's richtig gut wäre, würde ich's kaufen. Ja, es gibt ein paar Ups, die sind gut, ein paar Ups hat sich nicht so gelohnt, aber es schmerzt ja nicht so.
Es gibt einen richtig guten Java IEM Klein, der nicht über einen anderen Service drüber geht, sondern das direkt macht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Für den würd ich vielleicht mal so ein bisschen bezahlen.
Ich glaub, da müssen wir noch mal auf diese Background-Notification warten. Ich hab ja früher immer gesagt, wir haben kein iPhone, weil wir ja Drubber haben und das haben sie ja nicht. Ich hab mir meine Meinung geändert. Ich glaube, dass Drubber nicht wichtig ist auf diesen Telefonen. Man hat auch Spaß ohne. Man macht Twitter.
Wichtig wär's schon. Diese Notification-RP langsam.
Aber cool wär's nur, wenn's anbleiben würde.
Ja, ich denke, sie nehmen sich einfach noch ein bisschen Zeit. Weil derzeit sieht es nicht so aus, als ob ihr Umsatz davon abhängt.
Ich glaube, sie haben Angst vor dem Stromverbrauch, der dadurch unglaublich starkt.
Naja, das Notification-System wird da nicht sehr viel Stromverbrauch hinzufügen.
Also das ist...
Na doch, das glaub ich schon.
Eine schlechte App wird auch ohne Background-Notification oder eine schlechte App wird einfach immer viel Strom verbrauchen. Das ist einfach so.
Das kann schon sein, ja.
Also die können ja mit ihren Guidelines und was sie so vorschlagen, wie sie es verändern wollen, das können sie alles machen, aber wenn ein Programm einfach scheiße programmiert ist, dann nützt das alles nichts, dann wird es immer viel Strom verbrauchen. Auch Apple kann da nichts machen.
Nee, aber ich meine, für diesen Notification-Service, der wird viel Strom schlucken, schätze ich mal so.
Ich glaube, wenn man es richtig macht, nicht.
Also ich meine, man sieht ja, wie viel Push mehr. Vorgeschmack darauf, was der Notification-Service an Strom schlucken wird, kriegt man ja mit, wenn man Pushmail mal einschaltet. Weil da muss ja auch eine ganze Zeit eine IP-Verbindung offen gehalten werden, damit die Daten empfangen werden können, wenn welche anfallen, und dann sieht man ja, wie unglaublich der Stromverbot, also der...
Also eine IP-Verbindung an sich, die offen ist, frisst erstmal so keinen Strom. Aber wenn du Pushmail einschaltest...... ein Programm läuft und was damit tut, dann frisst es Strom.
Aber sobald du auf deinem iPhone Pushmail an hast und das nutzt, hält der Akku höchstens halb so lange, wie wenn du es ausschaltest.
Naja, weil das Ding dann regelmäßig was macht.
Und zwar, na gucken.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum man nicht irgendwie die eine Minute noch schnell hat, um seine Mails zu holen. Geht doch total flott. Also ich brauch da ja keinen Pushmail. Ich drück drauf, und dann macht's ein Wiss, und dann sind die doch da.
Damit man mitkriegt, wann sie kommen. Der Sinn der Sache ist nicht, dass man mitkriegt.
Aber dann müsstest du ja auch die ganze Zeit dein Ding offen haben, oder wie machst du das auch nicht, oder? Du guckst doch ab und zu mal nach, und dann drückst du einfach drauf. Und dann siehst du's.
Ich überleg jetzt auch gerade, warum das Pushmail eigentlich mehr Strom verbraucht.
Ich geh fest davon aus, wegen der offenen Datenverbindung.
Aber bleibt die Datenverbindung nicht sowieso die ganze Zeit offen?
Ja, man muss doch dann aber auch immer irgendwie wieder gucken. Alle fünf Minuten halt. Muss er kurz mal hochfahren.
Nee, das ist Pushmail.
Na, bei Push muss er ja eigentlich nicht gucken, sondern...
Er wartet, dass was passiert.
Aber Push halt, ist halt nicht Pull.
Nein, scheint er nicht.
Doch!
Weil dann würde er wirklich nichts verbrauchen.
Das ist auch das, worüber ich versuche, gerade nachzudenken. Ich komme gerade noch nicht auf so eine gute Erklärung.
Oder du kriegst so viel Spam.
Also ich würde einfach mal sagen, da es auf einer E-Mail-Adresse war, auf der Null Spam kam.
Das geht?
Ja, die war einfach sehr, sehr neu. Und darum ist meine Theorie, dass die offene Datenverbindung einfach mal Strom saugt ohne Ende. Dass das die IP-Verbindung ist.
Was soll denn da Strom verbrauchen?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich weiß, dass es auf einem Sony Ericsson-Telefon war, dass eine offene UMTS-Verbindung Strom gesorgt hat. Offene Datenverbindungen scheinen Strom zu spressen. Ich weiß nicht warum.
Tja, das müssen wir nochmal. Also rein jetzt vom GSM her und so weiter, das sind ja auch nur Datenpakete. Das ist jetzt irgendwie auch nicht anders, als ob dein Telefon auf eingehende Anrufe wartet. Also eine Datenverbindung, die aktiv rauspumpt, wo er senden muss die ganze Zeit, dass das Strom verbraucht. Das ist klar. Aber eine, wo er nur wartet, dass irgendwas passiert, ist eine andere Geschichte.
Vielleicht muss er auch irgendwie mal einen Idol schicken.
Wir waren beim Geld, aber wir können das Thema jetzt auch gerne mal abschließen. Es ist offensichtlich, dass Apple eine Menge Kohle macht und dem Laden geht es irgendwie gut. Mal gucken, ob das iPhone noch billiger wird. Dann kriegen die anderen aber echt Probleme.
Und der alte Steve lebt auch noch.
Ich bin erstaunt, wie schnell das ging.
Mit dem iPhone?
Ja, also die Zahlen haben mich echt platt gemacht.
Da kann man mal sehen, dass die Leute alle gewartet haben, bis das GPS und UMTS-Feature kamen. Das wussten wir alle und sind davon ausgegangen. Deswegen haben sie alle zurückgehalten. Das kann ja nicht anders sein. Es gibt auch noch andere Gründe, warum sie gekauft haben. Na, welche?
Na, der Upstore zum Beispiel.
Glaub ich nicht.
Doch, klar, Games. Die Leute kaufen einfach Games wie Blöder.
Also in Deutschland, was ich so im Bekanntenkreis mitgekriegt habe, zum Beispiel bei einer Person, die hier am Tisch sitzt, die unbedingt auf UMTS gewartet hat.
Bei dir, Tim.
Du guckst gerade zu fragen. Ja, was denn?
Na, du hast doch auf UMTS gewartet. Du hast gesagt, UMTS kauft das nicht.
Mein Gott, wir sind Nerds.
Aber die meisten nicht, die argumentieren so.
Du kennst ja auch nur Nerds.
Ich kann nicht nur Nerds.
Ja, natürlich, aber UMTS ist an sich keine...
Ich kann mehr nicht Nerds als du, glaube ich.
Gut, aber UMTS ist nicht wirklich wichtig zum Telefonieren. Das heißt, Leute, die nach einem Telefon gesucht haben, für die ist UMTS vollkommen unwichtig gewesen. Für mich ist es wichtig gewesen, aus Gründen, die den normalen Telefonbenutzer nicht interessieren.
Aber so siehst du es falsch.
Trotzdem, wenn du dir anschaust, was sie schon vorher auf Telefonen verkauft hat, also auch auf diesen anderen, die jetzt beileibe nicht so sophisticated waren, das waren Spiele. Das ist der eigentliche Markt gewesen, mit dem du da Geld verdienen konntest, waren Games. Und guck dir die portablen Konsolen an, guck dir den Erfolg der Nintendo DS an. Das ist die meistverkaufte Spielekonsole aller Zeiten, ist Nintendo DS. Und das verkauft sich nicht nur an Kinder, das verkauft sich zum Beispiel auch an Erwachsene, vor allem alte Leute.
Ich glaube eher, dass es das Marketing ist, was den Leuten gesagt hat, dass UMTS 3G ist der neueste Shit. Deswegen wollen das alle haben, ob man besser oder schlechter telefonieren kann.
Es ist natürlich auch der Hype. Es ist natürlich der Hype.
Wir wollen halt Google Maps haben hier und somit GPS, das ist doch total super. Und hier Wetterkarte, Aktien, Zeug, E-Mail.
GPS war für mich der totale Dealbreaker. Also das GPS, das hat mich gezogen. Und das ist auch immer noch das, was für mich den größten Nutzwert ausmacht an diesem Telefon, abgesehen davon, dass es so einfach funktioniert und sich bedienen lässt. Weil es gibt ja echt viele nette Applikationen, wo GPS echt sinnvoll ist.
Lass uns doch mal ein bisschen über Programme erzählen.
Na, erstmal Maps.
Maps, stimmt. Wobei das funktioniert auch ohne GPS ziemlich gut.
Ja, aber du weißt halt nicht, wo du bist.
Na doch.
Nur wenn du in deiner eigenen Stadt bist. Sag mal woanders. Und dann natürlich diese ganzen, was ist hier in meiner nächsten Umgebung? Da bist du mal in irgendeiner Stadt, so ist eine Tankstelle.
Ja, aber gerade in Städten funktioniert es wirklich ziemlich gut mit der Lokalisierung über WLAN und GSM. Ist das funktioniert?
Ja, okay, gut. Lokalisierung mit WLAN mag ganz gut funktionieren mit den Zellen, da greift das natürlich auch, da hast du recht. GPS ist dafür nicht notwendig. Für mich persönlich war GPS dann das Maß an Accuracy, das ich dann noch haben wollte. Naja, da können wir jetzt lange drüber sinnieren, warum sich die Leute ein iPhone kaufen. Tatsache ist, sie kaufen sich was und sie kaufen sich jetzt mehr eins, als ich gedacht hätte, dass sie das schaffen. Trotzdem, sie sind halt jetzt so in dem Bereich, wo ich dachte, dass sie irgendwann mal hinkommen, nämlich dass sie doch allen anderen Firmen enorm Ärger machen. So, können wir das Thema jetzt mal abschließen?
Ich dachte, wir wollten jetzt ein bisschen über Programme.
Ach so, von dem iPhone. Wenn wir da gerade sind, können wir das machen. Du hast Google Earth installiert und es müsste Google Earth empfehlen.
Google Earth ist super, aber sollte man eigentlich noch auf 101 warten, oder? Das stört ständig ab.
Es stört ständig ab, aber es bedient sich jetzt schon besser als das Google Earth auf meinem Mac.
Also es ist schön.
Es ist nicht so voll geladen.
Ja, und vor allem, man weiß auch sofort, was man machen muss, um irgendwie zu zoomen.
Bis auf das, bis den Winkel einstellen. Das hab ich eine ganze Weile für gebraucht.
Echt, das hab ich sofort erwartet. Ich wusste nicht sofort, wie das geht.
Ich hab's probiert und es ging nicht. Daraufhin hab ich gedacht, da muss es einen anderen Trick geben. Man muss da nämlich eine Weile warten. In welche Richtung man guckt, also dass man nicht von oben drauf guckt, sondern von...
Aber was benutzt du denn regelmäßig?
Was benutze ich regelmäßig? Sinks, das ist so eine kleine To-Do-Liste, die sich wunderbar mit Mac synchronisiert. Kostet einen Schweine Geldleiter 8 Euro oder so was. Aber es ist eine schicke To-Do-Liste, kann man über WLAN synchronisieren.
Hab ich versucht, eine Weile zu benutzen. Die Logik hat sich mir nicht erschlossen.
Hat das eine Logik? Ich dachte, da trägt man Punkte an und dann hört sich das.
Nee, da gibt es dann so, ob das nun To-Day ist oder nicht To-Day und dann marschiert das irgendwie hin und her. Dann ist es geplant irgendwann. Ich weiß nicht.
One Password?
Ja, das ist gut zum Nachschlagen, aber dass man wirklich die Passwörter automatisch übernehmen kann, funktioniert nicht, ne?
In Safari? Nee, das geht ja leider aufgrund von Safari nicht im Augenblick.
Ja, aber die machen doch irgendwas. Du kannst das so auswählen und dann lädt er so ein Webview und meint wohl, dass er...
In ihrem Programm laden sie dann ein Webview rein.
Ja, aber ich dachte, sie versuchen dann so einen Cookie zu hinterlassen, der dann auch von Safari aus benutzt wird.
Ach so, das sag ich gar nicht. Ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht ausprobieren.
Einen anderen Grund kann ich mir nicht sagen, aber funktionieren tut es nicht.
Ich schütze das, um regelmäßig mal irgendwelche PIN-Nummern nachzuschlagen, die eben dann halbwegs sicher abgespeichert sind. Dann hab ich ein kleines Programm, das heißt XBMC. Das ist für Leute, für die Freunde der gehackten Xbox. Es gibt ja dieses Xbox Media Center, wenn man eine alte Xbox hat, dann kann man da auf Xbox Media Center oder XBMC installieren. Das läuft mittlerweile auch auf Mac. Und das ist eine Fernbedienung dafür. Eine sehr, sehr hübsche. Kostet irgendwie 4 Euro oder so was. Und damit kann man dann schön aus dem Schlafzimmer heraus über WLAN steuern, welche Musik im Wohnzimmer läuft. Das ist eigentlich ganz großartig.
Ja, hier diese andere Bude, diese schicken Raumklang-Systeme. Sonos verkauft. Sonos heißen die. Haben jetzt auch so gerade eine Fernbedienung für die iPhone-Plattform rausgebracht.
Kostet die oder ist die kostenlos?
Gute Frage. Das glaube ich unerheblich, wenn du so ein Ding hast. Willst du es glaube ich haben, ob du nochmal bezahlst oder nicht?
Stimmt, das Gerät ist teuer genug. Da kann man auch nochmal ein bisschen Geld dafür nehmen.
Ich meine, letzten Endes haben sie mehr davon, wenn sie es kostenlos verteilen, denke ich mal.
Dann habe ich mir das Programm RRJDJ oder ich weiß nicht, wie das ausgesprochen wird. Hat das jemand von euch ausprobiert?
Ich habe nur vorgehört.
RJDJ, naja, ich habe es in dieser kostenlosen Version ausprobiert.
Ich habe mir die 2-Euro-Version, oder 3 Euro, was das kostet, geleistet. Finde ich sehr schick. Also man steckt mal ein Kopfhörer an, iPhone und dann eine virtuelle Droge, bezeichnen sie das. Und das hat wirklich was Drogenhaftes, dass man...
Also es ist so eine Real-Time Composing Application, würde ich das nennen.
Genau, die so Geräuschkulisse erzeugt. Sehr großartig.
Ist ja in der bezahlten Version aber auch nur das, was übers Mikrofon reinkommt.
Genau, aber es sind viel mehr Varianten zur Verfügung.
Was für Varianten?
Na es gibt hier so... Wie heißen die? Jetzt müsste ich Sets ja draus holen. Oder mal gucken, vielleicht kann ich das auch so sehen. Also in der Solovariante hat man nur einen Effekt, den man oben drauf legen kann und hier habe ich den Effekt. Ich glaube Echolon, Eargasm, Gridwalker, Loopinger, Neuer und Weltquantizer.
Weltenquantisierer.
Ja.
Finde ich sehr, sehr schick. Und die klingen alle ein bisschen anders und passen sich ein bisschen...
Na mach doch mal an.
Kriege ich das jetzt hier irgendwie rein?
Wieso musst du nur anschalten?
Nee, man braucht ja ein Headset.
Wieso?
Man braucht ein Headset. Ohne Headset geht das nicht. Warum? Keine Ahnung. Das sagt das Programm, wer beim Starten will.
Ach echt?
So, dann hol ich mal ein Headset raus.
Ach, das meinst du auch? Ach so, wegen der Entkopplung oder was?
Wahrscheinlich.
Die Programme können feststellen, dass ein Headset eingesteckt ist? Das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht. So. Wo ist denn das Ding gelandet? Ich hab zu viele Ups auf meinem Telefon.
Das wird jetzt gerade ein bisschen kompliziert. Ich muss jetzt hier mal...
Dennis, sag doch mal was.
Weiß nicht.
So, könnt ihr mal hören, ob ihr das gleich hört?
Und jetzt?
Na, das ist jetzt dieser Effekt.
Und kannst du es mal... Ist das maximal laut?
Das ist maximal laut jetzt. Und ist das dieser Echolohn? Das ist jetzt Echolohn. Jetzt mach ich hier mal Eargasen.
Genau, mach mal Eargasen.
Jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen was erzählen, damit da ein bisschen was kommt.
Genau, oder ein bisschen Beatbox machen.
Am lautesten hört man immer noch mich, weil hier das Headset ist.
Und das macht Spaß.
Also der Rhythmus hat jetzt nichts gebracht, oder? Also hat was, ich meine, es gibt dem Podcast eine ganz andere Atmosphäre. Es muss ein bisschen lauter sein.
Also für mich ist es tierisch laut. Ich muss das jetzt unbedingt loswerden.
Also mir ist nicht so ganz klar, wozu man, also ob man da jetzt wirklich, genau, halt mal da beide dran, dann ist es glaube ich ein bisschen lauter. Also ob man damit jetzt wirklich was Sinnvolles komponieren kann. Aber ich habe so ein paar Musiker gehört, die waren ganz angetan davon.
Also ich fand das einfach ganz witzig, mit so einem Kumpel zu gucken, wie der in der Kneipe saß und halb durchgedreht ist. Verlaute Begeisterung.
Na gut, die Frage ist, hält diese Begeisterung länger als eine Woche an? Da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Direkt nicht länger als fünf Minuten an, aber ich meine, es kostet drei Euro.
Naja, also drei Euro fünf Minuten, ehrlich gesagt, das wäre es mir dann nicht ganz so wert. Deswegen habe ich mir auch die kostenglose Variante runtergeladen.
Die reicht wahrscheinlich auch. Dann habe ich hier ein Programm, das heißt iBowl. Ich glaube, das ist super geeignet, wenn man unbedingt ein neues iPhone haben will. Und zwar, das ist so ein bisschen wie bei Navi. Man muss nämlich hier, ich demonstriere das jetzt mal hier live, also man hat hier so eine kleine Bowlingkugel drauf, da muss man die drücken.
iBowl.
Und dann kann man hier Bowlingkugeln schmeißen.
Bowling.
Und das gemeint ist, wie viel?
Spitzer haben?
Und man muss hier mittendrin diese Taste loslassen. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich hervorragend geeignet, um das iPhone aus der Hand zu schmeißen. Irgendwann bei Gelegenheit, gegen die Wand zu donnern.
Wahrscheinlich muss man demnächst noch genau so ein Sicherheitsgummi ranmachen, wie an diese Remotes. Genau, wenn du das iPhone nicht durch die Gegend schmeißt. Ja, so eine Kordel. Tja, hast du noch irgendwas Sinnvolles, oder hast du nur so Döneken? Weil diese Döneken-Software ist ehrlich gesagt nicht das, was mich jetzt interessiert, sondern Sachen, die du wirklich verwendest. Ich denke, alle anderen können wir einfach rauslassen. Sachen, die du jetzt seit zwei Wochen drauf hast und die wirklich einen Mehrwert darstellen. Weil, ich hab da was Nettes gefunden und dann, hm, ist was anderes. Ja, ich finde ja Twitterrific auch gut.
Ich finde es besser sogar als die Desktop-Version, weil Twitterrific gleich sofort das Alter des Eintrags anzeigt, wobei ich das auf dem Desktop irgendwie, hab ich da was verpasst oder geht das nicht?
Äh, das geht mit Mouse, Hover.
Ja, aber ist doch scheiße.
Ja, ist scheiße.
Das ist das Allerletzte. Also deswegen ist die auf dem iPhone voll super, voll schick, voll toll.
Also auf dem iPhone finde ich Twitterrific total scheiße, weil viel zu langsam. Das kreult so unglaublich scheiße.
Man kann sich aber nicht mal eben alte Tweets von irgendjemand anzeigen lassen.
Da nutze ich ja meinen eigenen.
Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwas von dir sehe, wie du irgendjemandem was antwortest so, und dann möchte ich von diesem irgendjemand mir mal die letzten zehn Tweets anzeigen, dann gibt es keine Möglichkeit das zu tun.
Also von den von den Nativen...
Man ist auf dem iPhone sowieso extrem ausgeschlossen von Twitter, weil wenn man mit dem normalen Safari, mit dem Mobile Safari auf Twitter kommt geht, dann kriegst du halt so eine speziell angepasste und vollkommen gefeatured drückte Variante und du hast einfach keine Möglichkeit, an deinen Twitter ranzukommen.
Und doch du gehst um, unten klickst du auf Standard.
Ich klick auf Standard? Und dann?
Dann kommst du auf die ganz normale Standard an.
Ist nicht wahr, ja? Echt, das habe ich übersehen.
Dafür ist diese Sendung da. Ich würde jeden mal noch was lernen. So wie mit dem Caps Lock.
So sieht es aus.
Fanden die alle voll toll. Hab ich ja gleich ganz heimlich während der Sendung getwittert.
Mein Supertipp.
Kann ja jetzt jeder sagen.
Ich hab den selber gefunden. Sollte ich jetzt mal raten? Du hast jetzt keine weitere ab mir. Jetzt hab ich es dir versaut.
Ich hab hier noch, doch Byline hab ich noch. Das ist so ein RSS Client, der mit dem Google Reader zusammenarbeitet und ich bin deswegen, ich geb's zu, ich bin von NetNewsWire auf den Google Reader umgestiegen.
Weil?
Weil dieser Byline so viel besser ist als das NetNewsWire auf dem iPhone. Ach echt? Weil er zum Beispiel auch Artikel archivieren kann, weil er viel viel schneller synchronisiert als NetNewsWire auf dem iPhone, was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe. Ansonsten NetNewsWire ist kostenlos, Byline kostet irgendwie auch drei Euro. Was hab ich hier noch?
Was ist denn daran besser jetzt? Also das hab ich nicht verstanden.
Schnell, schneller, viel schneller. Und du kannst dann auch, also kannst du über Wi-Fi sünden und er speichert dann die Artikel direkt auf dem Gerät. Und dann kannst du dementsprechend schnell die Anzeigen lassen, indem du einfach nur drauf tippst und dann sind sie so quasi sofort da.
Naja, wo wir jetzt schon beim iPhone sind, ich weiß nicht, Dennis, wolltest du noch einen Applikationstipp ablassen? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich irgendwas, ich hab eine Menge ausprobiert, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich irgendwas wirklich empfehlen kann zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Mein Lieblingsprogramm ist natürlich der Textaclient.
Der was?
Der Textaclient.
Was heißt Textaclient?
Ach, deine App. Jetzt darfst du endlich mal drüber reden. Na dann, plack mal.
Wie jetzt?
Gibt's den schon im Store?
Nee, noch nicht.
Ach so.
Also deine Applikation, was heißt Textaclient?
Na, das ist halt der iPhone-Client, damit man bei texter.com seine Dokumente, die man dort hat, auch auf dem iPhone sehen kann.
Was ist texter.com?
Dokumentenverwaltung, so wie Flickr für Bilder, das ist Texter für Dokumente.
Wie schreibt man das denn? TXTR oder was?
Genau.
Was für Texte?
PDFs, HTML-Snippets, Text-Snippets, Doc, EPUB, alles Mögliche. Also da sind sogar auch Bilder, hab ich gesehen.
Warum soll man das da hinladen?
Damit man sich auf dem iPhone angucken kann.
Genau.
Das kann ich doch auch direkt auf mein iPhone laden. Warum muss ich das dann auf die Webseite laden?
Das wäre nicht so kleinlich.
Weil man dann besser sharen kann mit den anderen Leuten. Kannst du bei anderen Leuten, bei den Buddies, in deren Texten gucken und so.
Ah, da ist der große Mitglied.
So wie bei Flecker halt. Wozu sollte man seine Bilder irgendwo hochladen? Erstmal, damit man die irgendwo hochladen kann, damit andere die sehen können. Klar, wenn du jetzt nur deine Texte für dich selber haben willst, dann macht man natürlich alles selbst. Aber wenn man es irgendwie sharen will, braucht man ja irgendwas, das hostet.
Ah, jetzt hat er's.
So wie Last of Empire Music, Flecker für Bilder und was gibt's noch?
Ich meine, so ein Foto ist natürlich auch etwas, was man sich mal eben reinzieht, so ein Text. Macht man ja nicht so, oder? Da hab ich ja schon das Web. Das ist ja schon voll mit Texten. Also warum soll ich dann nochmal das Web?
Dann kannst du da Texte natürlich suchen bei den anderen Leuten, alles, was bei dir im Public ist.
Das funktioniert ja irgendwie nicht. Erklär mir mal, wie das funktioniert. Wie besorge ich mir einen Account? Dann klicke ich auf Anmelden, dann passiert nichts.
Das ist nicht für Mac.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich bin ja hauptsächlich meinem Kleinen.
Okay, also du hast da einen Kleinen für gemacht. Und warum kommt der erst im Dezember? Weil er noch bei Apple ist und er wird jetzt drei Monate lang getestet.
Weil auf der Web 2.0 Expo vertönt wurde, dass der im Dezember kommt. Hat er schnell mal so gesagt, Elchefe. Und jetzt hab ich noch ein bisschen Zeit, um alles ein bisschen glätter zu machen.
Eigentlich sollte er erst nächstes Jahr kommen, oder was?
Nee, er sollte halt irgendwann mal kommen. Aber jetzt haben wir halt mal ein Datum, das ist auch ganz gut.
Geht uns Safari nicht.
Und danach wird dann weitergekastet.
Ich kann mich nicht anmelden. Behauptet, dass mein Benutzername zu kurz sei?
Ist wohl nur für Windows.
Wahrscheinlich.
Nee, ich hab ja auch einen bekommen.
Aber guck mal, ich hab hier geguckt.
Zu kurz steht doch da.
Ja, aber hier sagt 4 bis 20 Zeichen. Das sind eindeutig 6 Zeichen. Und der sagt, er wäre zu kurz, der Benutzername.
Ja, deiner ist zu kurz. Anmelden. E-Mail-Adresse. Passt, passt. Sind doch überall drei Häkchen da. Ich hab auch nicht die leiseste Ahnung, was hier los ist. Kannst du ja jetzt mal abbrechen machen und gucken, ob du dich einloggen kannst, mit dem genau was eingeben, was vielleicht geht sehr einfach.
Steht da noch Beta auf der Webseite?
Klar ist es noch Beta.
Aber das steht nirgendwo.
Nee, aber es müsste glaube ich noch so sein.
Es ist Beta, obwohl es nicht drauf steht? Ach ja, lass uns nicht mit dysfunktionalen Webseiten rumstarten.
Wir haben jetzt die Quartalzahlen durch, das heißt, zusammenfassen noch mal alles super, super. Da haben wir noch ein bisschen iPhone gequatscht, wollten wir aber später eigentlich machen.
Ja, aber jetzt haben wir damit angefangen, jetzt können wir das auch irgendwie... Ja, weil das hat ja sonst keinen Sinn.
Es sind ja so ein bisschen, muss halt auch ein bisschen jeder selber rausgehen, aber...
Du darfst ja jetzt auch quatschen.
Neue Gerüchte. Worüber?
Naja, mit weniger NDA.
Ja, ich hab auch schon neu gesigned, man muss irgendwie neu signieren.
Man muss ja ja sagen, dass man das jetzt auch zur Kenntnis genommen hat. Was darfst du uns jetzt alles erzählen, was du uns vorher nicht erzählen durftest?
Ja, kann ich euch genau erzählen und zwar, man darf über alles reden, was released ist. Das heißt, ich darf nicht über...
Die aktuelle Beta reden.
Aber über 2.1 darf ich reden. Aber über 2.2 zum Beispiel darf ich auch reden, weil ich krieg ja gar keine 2.2. Das heißt, ich darf drüber reden, weil ich ja das aus anderen Quellen hab. Wenn überhaupt.
Also mit ein paar Worten, das ist eigentlich genauso, wie es jetzt bei Macintosh Development auch war.
Genau.
Ne, weiß man nicht. Also ich meine, es gibt halt ein paar Meldungen, dass jetzt Street View in die Google Maps kommt, dass jetzt irgendwie Walking Direction und Transit vor allem drin ist. Das heißt, sollte sich die BVG irgendwann mal aufraffen, ihren Fahrplan in einem Google-kompatiblen Format zu posten, dann hätten wir auch mal Fahrpläne hier für ganz Deutschland wahrscheinlich, sogar weil die ja sowieso alle bei Hafer's gehostet sind. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob dieser mittelständische Betrieb jemals dazu in der Lage sein wird, seine Daten zu konvertieren.
Und man kann endlich das Dictionary-Correction-Zeugs da abschalten.
Stimmt.
Hooray, da warten ja alle drauf.
Ich hätte ja lieber ein Dictionary, was......invertiert funktioniert, in dem ich es schlicken muss, wenn ich es annehmen will.
So rum hätte ich es gerne.
So rum, aber ich meine, diese Worte in deutschen Dictionary, die er da vorschlägt, die gibt es nicht. Also in diesem Wörterbuch...
Eigentlich ist die Korrektur gar nicht das Problem. Das Wörterbuch ist das Problem.
Ich finde die Korrektur total gut.
Und er lernt irgendwie nicht. Ein Kumpel von mir meint, er unterschreibt seine SMS immer mit M-Punkt, weil er mich ja heißt. Und es schlägt immer MIT vor. Und er kriegt es nicht weg. Also er sagt jedes Mal nee, nee, nee. So angeblich lernt das Ding ja, aber ist irgendwie nicht.
Irgendwie lernt er nicht.
Dann muss er das mal in sein Adressbuch eintragen als Nickname.
Das ist zum Beispiel auch eine Sache, die mich nervt. Man kann nicht in den Kontext nach Nicknames suchen.
Ja, immer noch nicht. Das ist ein Drama. Es gibt doch wie eine teure Applikation im Store, die dir das erlaubt. Naja, aber Street View sieht ganz ordentlich aus. Und ich finde ja, also Walking Directions finde ich ja super, weil man will halt nicht immer überall mit dem Auto hin, sondern man will manchmal auch zu Fuß irgendwo hin.
Also gerade ich als Nicht-Auto-Besitzer.
Ja, aber ich hoffe, dass halt auch diese ganze Busgeschichte kommt.
Und, und, und, und, da musst du doch fast explodiert sein, als du was erfahren hast von Autofreude.
Ich hab gelächelt. Ich hab gelächelt, na klar, weil wir hier so eine absurde Diskussion gehabt haben, irgendwie die ganze Sendung über, mit diesem Podcaster. So und ich meinte ja, woher weißt du nicht, dass sie daran nicht arbeiten? Und jetzt sieht es sogar so aus, als ob dieser iTunes-Wi-Fi-Store, den ich übrigens noch nie benutzt habe, oder? Hab ich den schon mal benutzt? Also ich hab ihn bestimmt mal gestartet, aber ich hab damit jetzt keine Musik gekauft, oder so. Aber das Ding, es gibt einen Screenshot, da ist jetzt ein Podcast-Button drauf und das legt natürlich die Vermutung nahe, dass man eben über das iPhone, naja, zumindest Podcasts, subscriben kann.
Wenn man subscriben kann, muss man auch runterladen können, ansonsten alles andere wäre komplett albern.
Das würde ich auch meinen. Ich denke, es gibt eine gewisse Chance, dass in der nächsten Version vom iPhone so eine Funktionalität existiert. Und das wäre natürlich der Brûlard.
Das wäre so klasse.
Das wäre, also wenn es gut gemacht ist, es muss halt dann mit dem iTunes sich irgendwie so, aber auch, also es muss irgendwie diese Information an meinen iTunes auf meinem Rechner zurück sünden, dass jetzt das iPhone diese Episoden lädt.
Das sollten sie aber hinkriegen, oder? Also wahrscheinlich wird das dann einfach auf beiden Geräten laden, genauso wie es beim App Store funktioniert.
Das muss halt einfach sein.
Ich glaube, das kriegen sie hin. Das kriegen sie bannend.
Videogucken.
Videogucken? Dazu musst du in dein iPhone reinatmen?
Ich wollte gucken, ob Sound da ist.
Du bist abgelenkt. Erzähl uns mal lieber, was es mit diesem Bassband-Hack auf sich hat.
Wir waren aber gerade noch mit einem Bassband-Hack.
Da gibt es News, ja.
Und zwar, Sunday ist Fun Day. Also war Fun Day, weil diesen Sonntag haben die sich ins Bassband reingehackt und haben da wohl auch schon Änderungen dran vorgenommen.
Also sie sind das iPhone-Dev-Team wahrscheinlich.
Genau, Pumpkin und Konsorten.
Was ist das? Bassband?
Das Bassband ist der Teil, der gehackt werden muss, damit das Telefon anlockt wird.
Ist das jetzt die Modem-Firmware?
Das ist der GSM-Teil. GSM-OMTS-Teil.
Okay, vom neuen 3G-iPhone.
Vom alten haben sie es ja schon gehackt. Und vom neuen noch nicht. Da sind sie ja doll dabei. Also jailbreak ist es ja schon seit ewigen Zeiten. Aber Unlock geht halt noch nicht. Und da sind sie wohl gerade dabei. Und ich kann noch mal kurz die Webseite aufnehmen und gucken, was es schon News gibt.
Das war auf blog.iphone.dev.org ein Video, wo sie gezeigt haben, dass sie irgendwie den String-Dev-Team da aus ihrem Baseband-Modul rausholen können. Das kann natürlich auch alles gefaked sein. Das kann alles gefaked sein.
Bisher haben die keinen Scheiß gemacht.
Also die spielen da mit AT-Kommandos rum auf dem Baseband. Eigentlich erstaunlich, dass die immer noch mit AT-Kommandos da rumspielen. AT-Kommandos kennt man auch von früher vom Modem, wenn man dann AT-DDR einhält.
Das machen wohl immer noch alle so. Das ist deren Standardschnittstelle, warum auch immer.
Das ist krass, wie manche Sachen überleben.
Erstaunlich.
Der Haze Command Set ist das.
Der dürfte mittlerweile 30 Jahre alt sein, oder so was?
Haze Modems, ja ja, was haben wir denn jetzt? 2008, minus 30?
78.
Naja, nicht ganz. Haze Modems gibt es so seit 80er Jahren irgendwann. Und, mehr weiß man aber auch nicht.
Und Sie haben es geschafft, ein eigenes Kommando, das alle laufenden Prozesse auf dem Bassband gerade anzeigt, haben Sie drinnen? Was ja darauf hindeutet, dass es jetzt, also es klingt jetzt so als...
Also, Sie haben schon Änderungen dran vorgenommen und wenn Sie an einer Stelle was fixen können, dann können Sie es auch an anderer Stelle. Und das heißt, dass Sie irgendwann demnächst den Unlock da entfernen werden. Also den Lock entfernen werden.
Also du meinst, Sie kriegen das hin?
Klar. Jetzt sind sie ja drin.
Hat aber ganz schön lang gedauert.
Das klingt aber ein bisschen so, als ob...
Ich frage mich, warum?
Wir haben nichts gefunden.
Keine Sicherheitslücke?
Keine Sicherheitslücke? Also Sicherheitslücken haben Sie gefunden, weil sonst gibt es kein Gelb weg.
Nee, um ins Bassband rein... Das Bassband ist ja auch nochmal signiert, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Die Firmware da drauf. Und um da was reinzukriegen, brauchst du nochmal... Musst du nochmal eine Sicherheitslücke im Bassband finden? Ich glaube schon.
Übrigens jetzt nochmal kurz zu dem Haze-Standard zurückkommen.
Weißt du, wie das gesichert ist, dieser Bassband-Teil? Also was das eigentliche Problem ist?
Na der Bootloader, der lädt nur signierte Bassband-Software rein. Deswegen, bei dem alten First Generation iPhone hatten sie den Bootloader irgendwann gehackt und den so verändert, dass er einfach jedes Bassband-Firmware laden kann.
Akzentiert, egal mit was es signiert ist.
Genau, und deswegen solange du den Bootloader da patchst, 3.9 oder 4.6 war die Version, kann die da drüber machen und tun, was sie wollen. Du kannst immer einen gehackten irgendwie einspielen. Und das hatten sie wohl bei dem neueren 3G noch nicht geschafft und haben sie aber jetzt irgendwie hinbekommen. Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es immer noch der Bootloader, wo sie die Löcher alle dicht gemacht haben. Bei Apple kann ja dann gucken, über welche Lücken, die bei dem alten Bootloader reingekommen sind. Dann können sie den natürlich dicht machen. Und vielleicht hatten sie die Möglichkeit, einfach bei dem 3G nicht mehr.
Vermutlich nicht.
So, jetzt nochmal kurz zurück zu dem Haze-Standard. Ich hab kurz mal gegoogelt und gewickied. Und da steht, dass irgendwie the next major advance in modems was Smart modem. Damals hieß es auch schon smart, noch nicht halt Phone, sondern modem. Und das ist von Haze eingeführt worden, 1981.
27 Jahre.
27, ja passt doch. Jaja, und dann irgendwann dachte man mal, man würde da...
Mit 300 Bits muss man sich mal vorstellen. Das sind irgendwie geteilt durch 8. Sind das wie viel? 30 Zeichen die Sekunde waren das oder so? Etwas mehr?
Du hast ja noch die Start- und Stopp-Bits in der Regel. Das waren letztendlich 30 Zeichen pro Sekunde. Da konntest du noch richtig zugucken.
Da konntest du wirklich zugucken. Hast du für eine Zeile mehr als eine Sekunde gebraucht? Du hast 40 Zeichen pro Zeile. 40 wohlgemerkt, nicht 80.
Das ist so, wie man das so kennt.
Ja, da konnte der Drucker noch mitdrucken damals. Der Teletype.
Da konnte man fast noch so schnell lesen, wie es ging.
Na ja, also Drucker mit 30 Zeichen pro Sekunde.
War damals auch schon schneller, meinst du?
Gab's nicht. Nein, nicht schneller, langsamer.
Doch, die sind auch... Aber wohl schon mit 81.
Die waren nicht...
Gab's wahrscheinlich aber nicht für Konsumer.
81? Nö, da waren gut keine Ahnung. Also es gab diese industriellen Ketten Drucker, die waren natürlich schon schneller. Aber so diese Matrix-Drucker, die waren ja auch alle erst im Kommen, die waren ganz schön langsam. Das war so... Ich hab meinen Matrix-Drucker dadurch beschleunigt in seinem Druck. Ungelogen, indem ich ein Gummiband am Kopf befestigt habe.
Aber nicht an deinem Kopf, sondern...
An seinem Druckkopf.
Wie, damit er schneller zurückfährt?
Das Gummiband an meinem Kopf ist dafür da, dass ich nicht so viel Unsinn erzähle. Damit er schneller zurückfährt, genau. Und ich hab nämlich den Return Speed damit verdoppelt und dann fing er halt schneller wieder an zu drucken. Und von links nach rechts hat ihn das komischerweise nicht gestört. Es war noch ein unidirektional druckender Drucker. Für Leute, die damals schon dabei waren, handelte es sich dabei um einen Commodore MPS-801.
Hatt ich auch.
Ein uraltes, schlechtes Teil.
Und daher kommt noch, dass man beim PC bis heute zwei Zeichen braucht, um einen Zeilenumbruch darzustellen. Nämlich einmal den Carriage Return.
Das kommt auch von einer Schreibmaschine.
Also den Wagen wieder zurückfahren und dann den Line Feed. Eine Zeile nach unten. Darum sind das zwei Zeichen. Und der Carriage Return, habe ich mir sagen lassen, wurde vor dem Line Feed gesendet, weil der Carriage Return ja länger dauerte. Und dann konntest du während der Wagen zurückfuhr, konntest du schon den Line Feed, das Line Feed-Signal schicken, dass seine Zeile tiefer geht. Dadurch hat man dadurch nochmal eine Zehntel Sekunde gespart beim Zurückfahren des Wagens.
Der Max ist ein richtiger Hacker.
Von Druckern habe ich voll die Ahnung.
Carriage, Return, Line Feed. Die Wagen-Rücklauf-Funktion.
Die Wagen-Rücklauf-Funktion.
Ja, Tele-Types, alles sehr interessant. Da gibt es so einiges. Kann ich auch mal wieder auf den Chaos Radio Express verweisen. Vielleicht habt ihr schon mal reingehört hier, die Geschichte der Typografie. Super interessanter Podcast.
Den wollte ich mir tatsächlich schon hören.
Wo es wirklich von Gutenberg bis zu den Fonds geht. Und wir auch sehr viel Zeit mit den Satzmaschinen selber verbracht haben. Sehr interessant.
Hat man das nicht schon mal? Woher Stereotype kommt? Das musst du ja dann aus dem FS wissen. Hat man das hier?
Stereotypie, ja. So mit dem Doppel und so weiter.
Genau.
Wir waren wo? Wir waren beim Bassband. Und? Haben wir das jetzt abgehandelt?
Das haben wir erst mal abgehandelt. Ist noch nicht gehackt, aber sieht gut aus. Leute sollen die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben.
Also es gibt noch keinen Unlock. Gehackt ist es, aber es gibt keinen Unlock.
Es gibt noch keinen Unlock, ja.
Genau, aber klingt für mich ein bisschen so, als ob es ab sofort eigentlich erst wenn ich eine Slice-Arbeit wäre.
Klar, jetzt kommt die Arbeit. So drin sind sie, jetzt müssen wir noch ein bisschen was tun.
Genau, bisher war es tüfteln und beten, dass es klappt und wir wissen nicht, ob es überhaupt jemals geht.
Erzählen wollte es, dass ein Freund und wir wissen auch nicht, wie schnell das wieder weg ist. hat auch ein iPhone gekauft, aber ein gelocktes und damit das benutzen kann, hat er sich irgendwie aus Großbritannien so eine Turbo-SIM bestellt. Und die funktioniert anscheinend auch. Hat er heute geschrieben. Ja, es geht. Aber er hat auch gesagt, dass wenn er wohl mit dem iTunes sinken will, muss er die SIM immer rausnehmen, weil das iTunes dann sagt, SIM kenne ich nicht.
Kannst du das nochmal erklären? Turbo-SIM?
Ja, das ist doch irgendwie schon damals als das iPhone im letzten Jahr rauskam, 2007. Da gab es ja noch keinen Hack. Und damit die Leute es trotzdem benutzen können, gab es eine Turbo-SIM. Das ist so eine Art Proxy-SIM, wo du deine eigene SIM so drauf packst und die hängt sich so dazwischen. So eine Art Man-in-the-Middle-Attack und gaukelt dem Phone irgendwas anderes vor.
Echt eine AT&T-Karte.
Ja, irgendwie, dass sie doch eine AT&T ist, obwohl es eigentlich keine ist. Mit so einem kleinen Ultra-Mikro-Chip irgendwie mit drauf. So acht Pins oder sowas. Und der schummelt da irgendwie so ein bisschen rum. Und das ist die Turbo-SIM. Die ist auch ganz flach, ganz schmal, weil die andere muss ja auch noch mit drauf. Da musst du so in den Slot reindrücken.
Es gibt ja doch auch so Varianten, wo man dann an seiner Original-SIM-Karte was abschneiden muss.
An der Stelle der Chip passt und so. Also es gibt da ganz komische was. Und das ist auch nur noch als Folie und so. Also es muss ja total dünn sein, damit es auch zusammen mit deiner SIM noch ins iPhone reinpasst. Jedenfalls, das ist irgendwie nicht so das Dolle, weil du musst halt immer das Ding rausnehmen, damit das iTunes das dann erkennt und so.
Und woher hat er das, dieses iPhone?
Hat er irgendwie von einem Kumpel gekauft, der irgendwie, keine Ahnung, das nicht haben wollte oder was auch immer. Weil eigentlich kriegt man ja überall, also ich meine selbst, hab ich ihm auch gesagt, kauft eins aus Italien, wollt ihr nicht auf mich hören und dann kam an, ich hab jetzt mein Tätepunkt. Wie kann ich das jetzt anlocken, wenn ich meine, kannste nicht?
Selbst die Schweizer Geräte sollen wohl mittlerweile, dass man dann bei den entsprechenden, bei, ich weiß nicht, wie die entsprechenden Schweizer Provider heißen, relativ undiplomatisch sagen kann, ja ich hätte gern einen SIM-Unlock drauf. Dann sagen die alles klar, SIM-Unlock hier. Und dann dauert es zwei Wochen und dann hast du deinen SIM-Unlock für dein iPhone.
Mit nochmal extra Mark?
Nee, soll doch gar nichts kosten.
Obwohl es die da so billig gibt?
Obwohl es die da so relativ... Naja, so billig sind die ja auch nicht.
Also da wüsste ich ja, was heißt denn, hab ich mir sagen lassen, also aus welcher Hand kommt denn diese Information, aus der vierten oder aus der fünften?
Von jemandem, der sich jetzt aufgrund dessen eins in der Schweiz gekauft hat, der sich sicher genug war, dass das wirklich klappt. Also da werde ich so in ein, zwei Wochen erfahren, ob das tatsächlich funktioniert.
Find das mal raus! Das ist sozusagen noch nicht bestätigt.
Also so hundertprozentig noch nicht.
Wir sind ja hier der Podcast der hundertprozentigen Informationen.
Ah, stimmt ja. Gerade warst du Finanzsachen an.
300%! 300%!
Unsere Gerüchteküche ist berühmt dafür. Gut, ja, dann können wir mal hier iPhone mal Deckel drauf machen und ich würde ganz gerne noch mal auf die MacBooks zu sprechen kommen.
Da gab es ja neue, habe ich gehört. Nee, hatten wir schon in den letzten Endungen.
Na ja, da haben wir uns ja nur schon ausführlich drunterhalten. Nicht jeder konnte vielleicht der Diskussion folgen, weil das alles so ver...
Weil die uns verfolgbar war?...
so durcheinander gewurbelt war.
Also die wichtigsten Punkte waren ja wohl noch die der offenbaren Sachen mit der Grafikkarte und wie das nun mit dem Hybridmodus ist und so. SLE nennt sich das ja. Der andere Punkt war, ob dann nun 8 GB an Memory reingehen, weil Apple ja bisher sagt, dass es nur 4 unterstützt.
Genau. Von den beiden Themen müsstest du zuerst berichten.
Na, ich will über alles quatschen.
Ja, aber berichtest du zuerst?
Na, ich würde sagen, wir fangen mal mit der Grafikkarte an.
Die Grafikkarte.
Also MacBook Pro sind ja 2 drin.
Also kann man nicht nur on the fly umschalten, sondern könnte man theoretisch sogar gleichzeitig benutzen.
Genau, das nenne ich das asynchrone Hybridmodus oder irgendwas, weil der eine ist ja ein bisschen schwächer als der andere. Die können ja nicht Hälfte der Hälfte machen, das klappt ja nicht.
Heißt das, dass man sie nur beide zum Rechnen benutzen kann oder heißt das, dass sie auch wirklich beide Output erzeugen und dann irgendwie die gleichen...
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
Weil die gehen ja letzten Endes auf dieselben Ausgänge, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Dann müsst ihr auch genau die gleiche Qualität an Output erzeugen, weil wenn ich es mal richtig verstanden habe, dann sind die ja nicht ganz genau bei ihrem Erzeugnis, weswegen nämlich so Cut-Benutzer und so...
Wie die sind nicht ganz genau?
Na die rechnen nicht exakt.
Was rechnen die nicht exakt?
Na, ihre Bilder.
Ihren 3D?
Ja.
Wie die rechnen, ist nicht exakt?
Na nicht auf die zehnte Stelle nach dem Komma exakt. Deswegen gibt es Grafikkarten, die kosten irgendwie das Fünffache von den normalen. Und die sind dann so für Cut-Benutzer, die das wirklich exakt brauchen, wo jeder Pixel sitzen muss und auch immer wiederholt gleichmäßig sitzen muss. Und es sind genau die gleichen Karten, aber die kriegen einen anderen Treiber, der dann wirklich immer exakt das gleiche Ergebnis liefert.
Na ja, wenn es nur eine Frage des Treibers ist, dann ist es ja...
Dann könnten sie es machen, meinst du.
Dann könnten sie es ja machen. Also mit Cut meinst du jetzt CAD.
Weiß nicht, was es da noch so für Leute gibt. Aber 3D wahrscheinlich nicht mehr die Autobauer-Gehäusebauer oder weiss nicht...
Na ja, aber Photoshop will sich ja jetzt auch... CS4 verlässt sich ja auch teilweise auf die Grafikkarte schon.
Aber nur Nvidia, ne? Auch.
Das ist diese Beschleunigung... Ja, das haben wir auch letztes Mal schon angesprochen. Das ist ja diese CUDA Technologie. Im Prinzip geht es jetzt auch darin hin, dass CPUs und GPUs werden zusammenschmelzen. Also so wie es früher FPUs und CPUs gab es.
Was meinen Sie mit zusammenschmelzen? Von der Benutzung her oder von der Hardware her?
Von der Hardware her wird es eins.
Das glaube ich gar nicht. Macht doch temperaturmäßig keinen Sinn. Das schmilzt ja alles.
Temperaturmäßig? Ich meine, was macht denn eine Grafikkarte? Sie rechnet massiv. Das macht so eine CPU.
Heißer als eine CPU. Wenn die die zusammen packen, kriegen sie Wärme ja gar nicht mehr weg.
Heißer als eine CPU. Das hängt davon ab, wie du es baust. Naja, das ist ja nicht so, dass Grafik an sich generell wärmer ist. Das hat nur was damit zu tun, dass da mehr gerechnet werden muss die ganze Zeit parallel. Aber diesen Rechenbedarf hast du ja letzten Endes auch in deinem Programm bedienen können. Und jetzt sehen wir eh, dass die Parallelisierung voranschreitet. Einerseits durch Multicore, andererseits durch explizit parallele Instruktionssätze. Wie wir das auch schon mit Alti weg und MMX und SSI gehabt haben und immer noch haben und auch noch weiterhin haben werden. Bloß es geht ja jetzt eben hin, dass es so unified ist. Bei der Playstation, wie heißt noch vielleicht der Prozessor? Genau, die Zellprozessoren, da ist das ja auch alles schon recht nah beieinander. Die ganzen parallelen Instruktionskerne und die normalen Instruktionskerne. Und letzten Endes sehen wir ja auch schon allein die Tatsache, dass NVIDIA solche Chipsets macht. Dass sie sich sozusagen dieser Seite zunehmendem Maße annähern. Also es wird alles eins werden. CPUs und Grafikkarten.
Noch viel eher wird man es wahrscheinlich bei AMD und ATI sehen, oder? Weil die ja wirklich nur beides unter einem Dach haben. Weil NVIDIA müsste ja mit jemandem zusammenarbeiten.
Die Möglichkeit haben sie ja immer noch.
Intel hat keine eigene CPU.
Na ja, Intel und NVIDIA. Also irgendwann heiraten die.
Glaub ich nicht.
Warum nicht?
Na, weil Intel das alles selber macht. Da kaufen die nix ein, die machen die tot.
Na ja, aber was machen sie? Womit? Ich meine, bisher haben sie keine nennenswerte Konkurrenz zur NVIDIA an den Start bringen können.
Ja, aber trotzdem ist Intel mit 50 Prozent irgendwie Marktführer sozusagen.
Na ja gut, aber in jedem PC, den sie verkaufen, steckt dann halt auch nochmal NVIDIA drin.
Na ja, oder eben der eigene Grafikchipplatz.
Nee, also die sind führend, Intel.
Führend in was?
In integrierten Grafik.
In Units. Oder in Geld, was sie da verdienen. Das seh ich halt nicht so. Also NVIDIA hat auf jeden Fall einen riesigen Marktanteil und sie sind der Highend. Und warum sollte Intel sich nicht mit NVIDIA verheiraten? Ich meine, die ergänzen sich doch wunderbar, genauso wie sie AMD und ATI wunderbar ergänzt haben.
Die haben sich sogar schon mal gegenseitig aufgekauft, aber das haben sie offensichtlich nicht getan.
Also wäre an mir vorbei gegangen.
Aber die könnte man auch ein bisschen aus dem Knick können.
In Bezug auf die MacBooks, was ich jetzt interessant fand, ist, dass man könnte auch beide Chipsetze gleichzeitig, also die Grafikkarte auf dem Chipsatz könnte man parallel laufen lassen mit der Grafikkarte, die bei MacBook Pro noch mit dabei ist. Und das könnte wiederum heißen, dass sie eben von 32 Rechenkerne sogar auf 48 Kerne hochskalieren können. Also mit ihrem OpenCL wäre das dann eben auch wirklich gut nutzbar.
Dann gibt es ja, ist das jetzt mittlerweile eigentlich bestätigt, dass, das würde ja genau in die Richtung gehen, dass die neuen Grafikkarten in den neuen MacBooks H264 Decoding machen, also QuickTime ein bisschen entlasten. Das tun sie. Bei QuickTime den Prozessor entlasten.
Noch nichts weiter gehört.
Doch, doch, das tun sie.
Da ist ja ein neuer Treiber dabei.
Aber nur bei den neueren Modellen, also noch nicht bei den alten.
Bei den neuen Grafikkarten, bei den MacBooks und MacBook Pro wird H264 decoding in den Hardware.
Die alte Grafikkarte in den alten MacBook Pro Modellen war ja auch 8600MGT, was nur eine langsamer getaktete Version des 9600MGT ist. Und deswegen müsste der das ja dann auch können. Aber für den gibt es diesen Treiber halt eben noch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was für einen H264 die decodieren können. Also nur, wenn du H264 decodierst, dann heißt es ja noch nichts darüber, welche Profile du decodieren kannst. Da weiß ich nicht genau, ich kenne mich da nicht aus.
Also auf jeden Fall sollte es mit dem alten, in den alten MacBook Pro Modellen auch gehen. Zumindest die mit deren Videokarte.
Ja, also sicherlich ließe sich irgendetwas damit. Also mit Mac OS X geht es nicht. Sicherlich gibt es eine Beschleunigungsfunktion da. Oder sagen wir mal, es gibt generell Beschleunigungsmöglichkeiten in der Grafikkarte für Video-Wiedergabe.
Die sind jetzt für SnowLab, hat es sogar angekündigt. Wenn mich alles täuscht. Von Apple.
Apple hat irgendetwas angekündigt?
Nein, nicht angekündigt, aber ich glaube, sogar angekündigt, nach allem, was ich verstanden habe. Und das haben sie jetzt sozusagen vorgezogen. Ein bisschen. Mit. Jetzt muss ich mal, bevor ich jetzt noch mal komplett ins Foto...
Such doch mal die Quellen vorher raus und überprüf die mal und dann kommst du mit deinen Mussmaßungen. Tatsache ist, dass Nvidia meinte, man könnte Dinge halt gleichzeitig betreiben. Und das finde ich halt schon interessant.
Ja, muss man halt warten, bis die entsprechende Software von Apple dann nachgeschoben wird. Also die Treiber. Na, weniger Latenz, mehr Rechenpower.
Also...
Na, für wer das gut sein soll, die beiden Grafiker gleichzeitig zu betreiben...
Damit mein World of Warcraft schneller flutscht.
Na, weil nochmal 50% Rechenenergie dazu gibt.
Also ich meine, da müssen ja, also die Texturen müssen ja nochmal abgesch... Also die haben ja wahrscheinlich auch zwei getreinte Speicher und...
Wie geht's nur um die Recheneinheit dabei? Du kannst halt einfach nochmal 16 Kerne nutzen.
Also dir geht's um die Recheneinheit, Tim. Und Dennis, dir geht's um das World of Warcraft. Wo es nicht um die Recheneinheit geht. Das sind ja noch zwei unterschiedliche Dinge. Weil World of Warcraft, das macht ja mit der Grafikkarten im Augenblick nur für Grafik.
Das meint aber Nvidia schon, dass sie wirklich für Grafik, also für Rechner, sondern für Grafik gleichzeitig asynchron betreibt. Das ist bei Vista auch schon funktioniert. Sogar Siemens umschalten ohne Logout, ne?
Ja, wobei, weiß ich nicht, ob man das so ohne weiteres vergleichen kann.
Ja, angeblich ist das Vista-Grafik-Modell hier der Windows-Updater, so wie er bei Apple halt heißt. Window-Manager, ne? Der soll bei Vista ziemlich gut sein. Kann sein, dass der einfach mal noch ein bisschen mächtiger ist.
Da fällt mir ein, dass sich der auch nochmal, da gab es noch etwas Tate bei uns im Blog. Da muss ich jetzt gleich nochmal kurz nachschlagen. Da gab es jemanden, der Vista da groß Kredit gegeben hat.
Beim Windows-Manager?
Genau. Windows-Vista hat allen umgerufen, zum Trotz zurzeit eindeutig das modernste Grafik-Subsystem. Es sei nicht alle Scheiße, was Microsoft produziert, behauptet er. Dann habe ich nachgefragt, was daran denn moderner sei. Und dann legte er nach mit der Information, dass Vista eine vollständige Ressourcen-Virtualisierung für die GPU habe und es möglich sei, vom OS aus die Texturen von der Grafikkarte ins RAM auszulagern, dann den Treiber neu zu laden und alles zurückzuspielen.
Das ist aber auf dem Mac eigentlich auch geben.
Darüber habe ich keine Kenntnis. Also da könnte ich jetzt nur mutmaßen, was das jetzt eigentlich für eine konkrete Auswirkung hat. Also mir ist nicht klar, wann man das braucht.
Wenn du von einer Grafikkarte zu anderen umschalten willst.
Das klingt doch genau nach dem.
Von der einen zur anderen.
Ja, on the fly.
Du nimmst die Texturen raus, aus der einen Grafikkarte, packst sie in den Rahmen.
Also es bezieht sich jetzt nur ums Umschalten.
Spielt es den Treiber um?
Das ist ja auch wichtig.
Nein, wahrscheinlich ein Schalten ist ganz wichtig.
Na, Umschalten oder gleichzeitig. Das ist am Ende so ein bisschen das Ähnliche. Du musst halt dann auch da mal Sachen umlagern und musst halt beide benutzen können.
Genau, wenn du nicht zwei Grafikkarten gleichzeitig nutzen willst, dann musst du auch Textur nicht hinfallen.
Welcher Konstruber hat denn zwei Grafikkarten?
MacBook Pro zum Beispiel.
Ja, jetzt.
Genau, darum geht's ja.
Aber du kannst ja auch support the future.
Wie oft schaltest du da hin und her?
Na, wenn man sich jedes Mal ausloggen muss. Nicht allzu oft. Aber wenn einfach z.B. mein Betriebssystem feststellen könnte, Moment mal, jetzt werde ich gerade zu langsam. Jetzt schalte ich mal um auf die andere Grafikkarte, weil jetzt die iTunes-Visualisierung zu viel brauchen.
Ja gut, aber hier ist die Rede von es sei modern. Wenn es jetzt wirklich eine Funktionalität handelt, die ausschließlich für das Umschalten zwischen zwei Grafikkarten...
Ich glaube nicht, dass die ausschließlich dafür zuständig ist.
Na ja, dann frage ich mich wofür das eben relevant ist.
Das wird wahrscheinlich ein Abfall-Effekt sein.
Dann den Treiber neu zu laden. Welchen Treiber? Dann sagt er auch noch D3D10-Applikationen. Profitieren davon automatisch, da sie einfach alles mal laden können. Und die Rantalm sorgt automatisch dafür, dass wenn etwas nicht in den V-Ram passt, die Sachen sogar bis von der Festplatte gestreamt wird. Dass wenn etwas nicht in den V-Ram passt, die Sachen sogar bis von der Festplatte gestreamt wird.
Nee, das klingt doch eigentlich logisch. Und zwar, die Applikation sagt, ich brauch folgende Texturen. Und mir eigentlich wurscht, wie viel V-Ram die Grafikkarte hat und wenn es nicht reinpasst, dann ist das Betriebssystem selbstständig in der Lage zu sagen, ok, dann pack ich mal den Teil jetzt noch mit, eben nicht in die Grafikkarte direkt in den V-Ram, sondern in den Arbeitsspeicher, an die CPU. Und wenn selbst dafür nicht mehr genügend Speicher da ist, dann zur Not auf die Festplatte. Dann wird es natürlich hakelig wie Sau.
Das macht das ein Power mit Bildern auch schon. Du sagst ja Load Image aus deinem Bundle. Und wenn da irgendwie kein Platz mehr ist, schmeißt du das raus und kannst von allein auch wieder nachladen. Gerade auf dem iPhone ist das ganz viel mit Reusing und so.
Gut, also klingt so, als ob beide Betriebssysteme da eine identische Funktionalität haben, wenn du mich fragst.
Also ja, das Vista...
Da müssen wir nochmal... Ich meine, er meinte noch, dass die Low-Level-Hardware-Treiber irgendwie vollständig im User-Space laufen bei Vista. Ist mir auch neu.
Na doch, da hat... Also die Low-Level-Grafikkartentreiber?
Low-Level-Hardware-Interface heißt es hier. Welcher Hardware sich das bezieht, weiß ich nicht. Er meint wohl alle. Sodass man Treiber neu starten könnte, ohne Plus-Screen. Aber wie auch immer, ich meine, da bewegen wir uns etwas wieder mal im inkompetenten Raum. Wir haben uns, glaube ich, alle nicht ausführlich mit Vista auseinandergesetzt. Das war auf jeden Fall hier die Kritik, die kam. Tatsache ist, dass, Dennis meint, dass das jetzt bei Mac OS nicht sehr viel anders sei mit der Ressourcen-Virtualisierung. Ich weiß es nicht.
Also ich meine, Apple kann offensichtlich noch nicht im laufenden Betrieb zwischen zwei Grafikkarten hin und her wechseln.
Ja, aber wir wissen nicht, warum sie das nicht tun.
Ich glaube, das kommt noch.
Vielleicht können sie das, aber sie haben halt irgendwie...
Natürlich wird es noch kommen, aber im Augenblick kriegen sie das offensichtlich noch nicht auf die Reihe.
Du müsst ja dann auch allen Programmen sagen können, dass sie jetzt ihre Grafikkarte unterm Arsch weggenommen bekommen und das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum sie das nicht machen. Aber das hatten wir letztes Mal auch schon. Das ist neuer Aspekt, die Sache mit den 8GB. Ich hatte ja gemutmaßt, dass meiner Meinung nach 8GB durchaus auch möglich sein könnten. In den MacBooks. Oder auch in den MacBooks Pros. Und mittlerweile ist es auch bestätigt worden von Nvidia, dass das ginge. Also diese Chipsets können das. Und irgendjemand bei MacFixit hat da auch mal RAM reingesteckt mehr. Mit unterschiedlichen Ergebnissen, die 8GB, die sie reingeschraubt haben, haben wohl nicht funktioniert, aber als sie mal nur 5GB nachgerüstet haben, ging das.
Na doch, die 8GB haben auch funktioniert, haben aber das System instabil gemacht.
Woran auch immer das Gelegen haben mag. Kann auch das RAM gewesen sein. Was weiß ich, was die da für RAM hatten.
Weil sie 5 reinstecken und da mehr als 4 kommen, dann heißt es ja, dass auch mehr als 4 gehen. Ist ja auch egal, dann gehen auch 6.
Genau, aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass da 8 GB geht. Irgendjemand meinte dann, das würde Mikro S10 nicht unterstützen.
In den Mac Bros unterstützen?
Das ist ja auf jeden Fall schon.
Seit Ewigkeiten kann der Mac mehr als 4 GB unterstützen.
Na, solche Ewigkeiten kann es noch nicht sein.
Seit Tiger.
Weil man braucht ja halbwegs 64-Bit-Betriebssystem.
Das Betriebssystem muss nicht 64-Bit sein. Er muss bloß mit einem 64-Bit-Adress-Base umgehen können. Und das kann Tiger. Tiger kann mehr als das.
Tiger kann mehr als 4 GB.
Das ging ja schon im Mac Pro.
Du hast halt nur pro Prozess nicht mehr als 4 GB.
Genau. Und jetzt bei Leopard kannst du halt auch 64-Bit-Prozesse haben, sodass eben auch ein einzelner Prozess mit User-Interface mehr als 32 Bit hat. Das ging vorher im Background-Prozess auch schon, also auf Unix-Ebene. Konntest du auch schon 64-Bit machen unter Tiger. Bei Leopard hast du jetzt eben auch das genau, auch im User-Interface. Und demnächst heißt es da übrigens jetzt auch in der Gerüchteküche um Snow-Leopard, und da sollten wir jetzt sowieso mal drauf kommen, dass sogar ein 64-Bit-Könnel im Gespräch ist. Das heißt Snow-Leopard könnte auch als 64-Bit-Könnel da herkommen.
Genau. Nein, nicht könnte, sondern kommt, weil da gibt es ja schon die Doku, wie man das Ding benutzt. Und zwar kann man mit den Tasten 4 und 6 sein Könnel im 32-Bit- und 64-Bit-Mode. Warum kommen die überhaupt auf 4 und 6? Was hab ich denn für ein Zeug gelesen? Gleichzeit 4 und 6? Hört sich eigentlich nach IPv4 und IPv6 an. Aber nee, da stand 4 und 6. Da gibt es doch eine neue Apple-Gerüchteküche-Seite. Gibt es die? Ja, Apple Archive oder sowas?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wie über den Snowlap hat gerade so viel Infos raushauen hier?
Also erstmal ist klar, es gibt einen neuen Finder tatsächlich. Der in Coco geschrieben ist, das erste Mal.
Teilweise.
Naja, ich hab von Re-Written, genau, Parts Re-Written in Coco. Das ist das, was ich gelesen habe.
Gibt es denn überhaupt Mixed-Carben-Coco-Applikationen? Ernsthaft?
Das weiß ich. Alle möglichen. Aber es ist für Carbon-Applikationen möglich, Coco-Teile zu integrieren. Du kannst Teile in Coco benutzen, auch wenn du an sich auf Carbon basierst. Das ist jetzt nicht so komplett entweder oder, sondern es ist immer beides da.
Ich dachte, da müsste man entweder sagen entweder oder.
Nee, nee.
Dann QuickTime 10 oder X oder wie auch immer das heißen wird. Also auf jeden Fall mit dem X hinten wird es bei Snow Leopard geben. Das ist nämlich auch das mit der GPU-Beschleunigung. Daher kommt das.
Ja, aber das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues.
Nein, im Moment, man hat es eben gerade noch gesagt, dass...
Na, das ist ja schon lange bekannt, dass QuickTime X kommt.
Ja, und das wird dann dieses H.264-Decoding-Inner-GPU können. Das ist von Apple angekündigt worden. Daher kommt diese Information.
Ja, das wird ja auch mal Zeit.
Aber was ist da dran jetzt so doll? Ich meine, das geht doch jetzt schon.
Ja, das ist...
Nee, das geht jetzt noch nicht.
Doch, das geht jetzt schon auf allen neuen MacBooks und MacBook Pros.
Genau!
Ich meine nicht das Feature, sondern an sich. H264, also ich meine...
Nee, nee, Moment, Moment, Moment. Es war eigentlich für Snow Leopard angezogen. Es ist jetzt aber schon bei den neuen MacBook und MacBook Pros vorhanden, dieses Decoding. Erstmal nur in dieser Grafikkarte. Mit Snow Leopard ist es generell angekündigt.
Das wollen wir mal sehen. Das wird dann auch schwer von der Grafikkarte abhängen, weil eine Grafikkarte, die dein Profil nicht unterstützt...
Klar, wenn man Rechner ohne Grafikkarte hat, dann kann er das nicht.
Hier steht es nochmal. Die News-Site heißt worldofapple.com. news.worldofapple.com. Und da steht, dass man die Tasten 6 und 4 runterhalten muss, um in den 64-Bit-Modus zu booten.
Das klingt doch sehr logisch.
Aber man hätte dann wohl keinen Sleep-Mode-Support und all so eine Sachen. Also das ist schon noch ein bisschen unfertig.
Das würde man wohl meinen. Aber sie arbeiten dran. Ich meine, ihr könnt mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie das auch erstmal weglassen.
Sleep-Mode? Oder 64-Bit-Mode?
64-Bit-Könnel. Weil ich weiß jetzt nicht, was sie unbedingt zwingt, den Kernel in 64-Bit zu compilen.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was bringt man für Vorteile. Also dann könnten wahrscheinlich die Treiber alle noch auf den 64-Bit-Adress heraufzugreifen.
Der läuft schneller.
Es bringt Speed.
Es bringt Speed auf Intel-Prozessoren.
Ja, auf modernen Intel-Prozessoren.
Auf PowerPC nicht so, weil die hatten schon viele Register. Aber unter x86, die können mehr Register benutzen im 64-Bit-Modus.
Genau. Also insofern ist es schon nachvollziehbar, warum sie das wollen, weil theoretisch könnte es dann schneller laufen. Ob es dann auch wirklich signifikant viel schneller läuft oder nicht einfach nur mehr RAM frisst, ist etwas, was nur Apple beantworten kann.
Es wäre aber nur der Kern, der schneller läuft, weil die Programme könnten natürlich auf diese zusätzlichen Register, wenn die für 64-Bit-kompiliert sind, schon so zugreifen.
Richtig. Also alles, was jetzt 64-Bit-kompiliert wird, kann schon schneller sein. Natürlich ist es nur der Kern, wenn man sich anschaut, wie viel CPU der Kern wegfrisst, wenn was läuft, dann läuft natürlich auch alles schneller. Ich denke, sie werden es machen. Ich glaube, vom Feeling her, denke ich mal, sie werden es machen.
Was hat das noch für Konsequenzen? Also man braucht dann wahrscheinlich unglaublich viele neue Treiber, Grafikkartentreiber sowieso, kriegt man ja wahrscheinlich nicht viel von mit.
Von Apple. Welche Treiber hast du, die nicht von Apple sind? Kölner Extensions, so. Also mir fällt da fast nur mein USB-KeySpan ein.
Das ist mal eine gute Frage. Da muss ich echt mal schauen.
Weil das ist nämlich wieder der Vorteil, den Apple hat, so. Die bauen einfach alle ihre Treiber. Kurz mal 64-Bit neu in deiner Ruhe. Bei Microsoft, die sitzen da 5 Jahre, um irgendwie ihre 6000 von Treiber irgendwie für alle anderen Firmen neu zu machen. Nicht mehr für ihre eigenen Produkte.
Na ja gut, das ist für Apple insofern ein Problem, als dass wenn Leute im 64-Bit-Modus ihren Rechner betreiben, sie halt wirklich auch alle Treiber, die sie haben, auch im 64-Bit-Modus neu bekommen müssen.
Ja, aber die haben auch alles in einer Hand. Also die können das ja schnell machen.
Na ja, es gibt ja auch Third-Party-Treiber-Anbieter.
Ja, aber nicht so viele wie bei Windows.
Lass doch mal Windows raus, das interessiert uns doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Also ich hab hier die Virtual Box, die einen eigenen Treiber anbieten, wahrscheinlich für das Nutt, also für das Netzwerk, Netzwerkfähigkeiten innerhalb der Virtual Box. Also Virtual Box ist so eine kostenlose Virtualisierung.
Da kommen doch alle Jungs auf eine Hand voll, oder?
Das sind nur ganz wenige, natürlich. Das sind extrem wenige. Ich glaube, Little Snitch hat auch eine Extension, die sehr, sehr weit unten steckt, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Ja, Little Snitch hab ich hier. ITV hat irgendwie ganz viele Treiber. Dann gibt es diverse Drucker.
Parallels hatte definitiv auch welche.
HP Design Jet Series hab ich hier in Treiber. Das ist hier, damit er diesen ganzen Schnickes mit Scannen übers Netzwerk und so weiter macht. Warum da unbedingt eine Kernerextension im System sein muss, weiß ich nicht.
Und die werden zwar von Apple mitgeliefert, aber wer weiß, wer die schreibt. Wahrscheinlich schreibt die HP selber.
Soundflower. Na gut, das sollte sich schnell compilen lassen. Aber das muss halt immer auch alles erst mal stattfinden. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich... Ich denke, sie werden das relativ elegant hinbekommen.
Wie sieht's denn MacFuse und sowas aus, also diesen ganzen Dateisystem-Treibern? Die müssten doch auch als Kernel-Extension vorliegen.
Ich wusste es ja eigentlich unten. File System on New Zealand, eigentlich müsste es ja genau...
Ja, aber es klingt sicher da ein. Also es gibt sicherlich... Es gibt Anpassungsbedarf. Und es wird nicht vollkommen schmerzfrei sein. Von daher kann es auch gut sein, dass sie Snow Leopard auch so ausliefern, dass man explizit sagen muss, du bootest jetzt im 64-Bit-Modus, damit es für die meisten Leute erst mal 32-Bit ist und voll kompatibel. Aber wer jetzt Bock hat, es umzustellen und sagt, ich hab eh nur alle Treiber, die ich brauche, ich installiere jetzt auch nichts anderes mehr, ich hab lieber nochmal 5% mehr Speed, die betreiben es dann so.
Vor allem muss Apple auch nur die Treiber neu machen für einen Rechner, die überhaupt diesen 64-Bit-Mode unterstützen. Das heißt, das ganze alte Zeug... Wieso? Da stand nix von PowerPC.
Ich rede von den meisten. Das haben wir vorhin schon festgestellt, dass die meisten Macs Intel sind und auch erst Core 2 Duo sich richtig gut verkauft hat.
Ist ja dann auch nicht viel. Was haben sie denn da? Die haben halt die Core 2 Duo-Plattform mit den passenden Hardwaren irgendwie. Also...
Na, alles was Core 2 Duo ist und so weiter.
Ist ja nicht so viel. So viel Hardware haben sie ja nicht. MacBook, MacBook Pro, Mac Pro, iMac und...
Naja, halt alle. Mac Mini, alle halt. Alle Macs, die sie verkaufen.
Das ist nicht so viel.
Das sind halt alle.
Verschiedene Hardware. Ja, aber es ist nicht so viel verschiedene Hardware.
Den Vorteil haben sie generell. Sie werden das schon hinbekommen. Ich meine, sie haben dann relativ schmerzfreien Weg gewählt. Und ich rechne eigentlich mit nichts anderem, als dass diese ganze 64-Bit-Geschichte in wenigen Jahren durch ist.
Ende 2009.
Ohne größere Schmerzen. Also ich wüsste nicht, was da jetzt besonders wehtun soll.
Enden nächsten Jahres erzählen, dass die Transition ganz super gelaufen wäre.
It's complete.
Das wäre aber tatsächlich ganz interessant, aus dem Aspekt heraus, dass ich habe mal bei Apple Insider einen fantastischen Bericht über, leider heftig über vergessen, wie es denn aussieht mit der 64-Bit-Umgebung auf Intel und PowerPC und Mac OS X versus Windows. Und die haben die steile These aufgestellt, dass Apple ja schon jetzt einen höheren 64-Bit-Betriebssystem Marktanteil hätte als Microsoft. Weil, beim Windows, braucht man ja von Windows Vista, braucht man ja explizit eine 64-Bit-Version, die aber genau wegen dieser ganzen Treiberproblematik keinen Mensch fährt. Oder kaum jemand. Nämlich irgendwie, ich glaube, 2 oder 3% der Windows Vista User. Und wenn man da mal unauffällig hochrechnet und dann mal guckt, wie viel sind denn 2 bis 3% von den Windows Vista Installationen, versus wie viel sind denn 100% der Mac OS X Installationen, dann dürfte Mac OS X im Augenblick das meistinstallierte 64-Bit-Betriebssystem überhaupt sein. Und mit Snow Leopard wird es noch viel mehr.
Aber das Vista läuft dann wahrscheinlich jetzt schon, wenn die Leute es benutzen würden, mit einem 64-Bit-Könnel, den wir ja noch nicht haben.
Genau, also das ist dann wirklich...
Okay, da muss man ja schon noch ein bisschen warten. Natürlich. Also bisher ist da noch nichts größer oder besser oder weiter.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel, dass deine Programme, also dass dein Betriebssystem überhaupt mehr als 4 GB Arbeitsspeicher oder 4 GB Arbeitsspeicher anspeichern kann.
Das können die unter Vista auch.
Das kriegen die mit einem 32-Bit-Vista in vielen Fällen nicht hin. Oder eigentlich nie.
Aber du kannst auch mehr als 4 GB in einen Windows-Rechner stecken.
Du wirst aber nicht viel davon haben.
Na doch, 4 GB pro Applikation maximal.
Nee, das steht genau in diesem Artikel drin. Alles sehr ausführlich, dass das nicht geht. Und zwar ist das sogar bei einigen Maschinen so, dass wenn man nämlich besonders tolle Grafikkarten hat, die mehr als, ich glaube, einen halben GB Grafikkartenspeicher hat, weil das ja nochmal in diese 4 GB mit reingespiegelt wird, hat man dann knapp über 2 GB tatsächlich nicht nutzbaren Arbeitsspeicher, wenn man 4 GB reinsteckt.
Das war der ältere Artikel, ne, glaube ich.
Das ist ein mehrteiliger Artikel hier bei Apple Installer. Den sollte man dann auf jeden Fall verlinken und vor allen Dingen auch alle Teile verlinken.
Wie viel Prozent von allen Vista-Installationen sind denn wohl 64 Bit?
2 bis 3 Prozent waren es laut diesem Artikel.
2 bis 3 Prozent aller Vista-Installationen sind 64 Bit? Na dann ist definitiv mehr Mac OS X 64 Bit auf dem Markt. Ich hab jetzt mal hier bei NetApplications geschaut, die das so in der Pause machen.
Aber gibt's da halt noch gar keinen 64 Bit-Könnel für OS X? Also bisher?
Ja, aber alles aus dem Kernel?
Nein, der Kernel nicht, aber du kannst 64 Bit-Anwendungen fahren.
Ah, hier guck.
Ah, ok, Anwendungen.
Hier, so sieht es zum Beispiel mit diesem Alienware-PC aus. Der hat nämlich dann noch...
Das kann noch keiner sehen, wir sind doch im Podcast.
2,2 GB.
Du musst beschreiben, was du siehst.
Da ist ein Bild von einem Dell-PC, der aussieht wie ein Alien, darum Alienware heißt. Und der braucht MMIO. Was ist MMIO?
Was ist denn das überhaupt, was du da soller? Wie ist der Titel dieses Dokuments?
Das ist dieser Apple Insider-Artikel. Road to Mac OS X. Xnolab hat, wie es mit 64 Bit aussieht im Betriebssystem, wie es auf der Plattform aussieht, also mit der Santa Rosa Plattform, die wir mittlerweile alle in unseren MacBooks drin stecken haben wahrscheinlich, und wie viel Arbeitsspeicher man nutzen kann. Und da sieht es einfach mal so aus, dass man auch mit modernen Chipsetzen mit einem entsprechenden 32 Bit Windows, was man in einem Spielrechner wahrscheinlich drin hat, weil da braucht man die ganzen vielen Treiber für, von seinen tollen 4 GB Arbeitsspeicher gerade mal so 2,2 nutzen kann. Das ist schon ziemlich mager.
Ich will jetzt nicht den Anti-Apple-Typen machen, weil ich ja auch schon immer sage, Apple ist evil. Und ich bin schon auch Apple-Fan. Nur mal klarstellen hier nicht, dass die Leute da irgendwie unseren Kommentarlings voll schreiben. Aber das MacBook zum Beispiel hat ja auch integrierte Grafik, also nicht in einen eigenen, sondern im Chipset-Zelt mit drin oder diese Intel GMA oder wie die heißen. Und die schnappen sich doch auch ihren RAM vom normalen Speicher. Also stimmt das nicht so ganz da? Und in dem Fall hat die die PC-Kiste da halt ziemlich viel, nämlich ein Gigabyte, was man mir aufmacht.
Nein, nein, nein, jetzt verwechselst du was. Und zwar ist das zwar V-RAM der Grafikkarte, also das ist schon auf der Grafikkarte nochmal separat drauf. Du hast also ein Gigabyte Video-Arbeitsspeicher auf der Grafikkarte und das nochmal vier Gigabyte im Rechner drinne stecken. Ist das aber so, dass dieser V-RAM mit in diese vier Gigabyte reingemapped werden muss in diesen Speicherbereich und das geht von deinem tatsächlich nutzbaren Arbeitsspeicher ab. Das ist jetzt nicht dieses Spielchen, dass du...
Du hast doch bei meinem Rechner hier zum Beispiel auch so, wenn ich hier vier Gigabyte reinstecke. Also ich hab hier so einen MacBook Pro Ende 2006. Wenn ich hier, also Core 2 Duo, wenn ich hier vier Gigabyte reinstecke, hab ich auch nur 3,2 übrig und da wird auch alles möglich abgezogen.
Bei mir nicht.
Nee, du hast ja auch schon wieder eine Version neuere.
Darum geht's ja.
Du kannst ja bei dir vier reinstecken und hast dann auch vier.
Was du da abgezogen bekommst, ist das, was der Colonel braucht. Aber du kannst vier Gigabyte RAM nutzen für dein gesamtes System. Was halt auf Windows nicht geht.
Okay.
Das ist so. Da kann ich übrigens auch noch mal ein Car's Radio Express-Ausgabe empfehlen zu dem Thema, nämlich die bei Mac OS X. Da kommt das ausführlich zur Sprache, mit dieser 3-Gigabyte-Grenze bei Vista. Dass jetzt aber noch mal ein ganzes Gigabyte nur für V-RAM-Mapping freigehalten wird, ist mir neu.
Das passiert nur, wenn du entsprechende Grafikkarten hast.
Das hängt von der Grafikkarte ab.
Das hängt, wenn du eine Grafikkarte hast.
Es gehen davon aus... Dann einfach weniger. Aber du kannst auf jeden Fall definitiv nicht 4 Gigabyte RAM einfach so nutzen.
Du kannst nicht 4 Gigabyte RAM nutzen. Und wenn du eben ein High-End-System hast, also ein Spielerechner, wo du sagst, ich stecke da richtig Asche rein, ich pack da die geilste Grafikkarte, die ich mir vorstellen kann rein, was ja nicht so ein unvorstellbares Szenario ist, dann steckst du da schön 4 Gigabyte rein, hast aber nur knapp über 2 Gigabyte.
So, jetzt hast du vorhin gesagt, 2-3% von Windows Vista sind 64-Bit-Installationen. Woher wissen die das?
Das wissen sie, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob sie 2-3% sind, also das sind Zahlen, die von Microsoft stammen, und zwar was sich bei ihren Microsoft-Soft-Windows-Updates meldet.
Ach so, ok, was Microsoft selber meint, wie es sei.
Genau.
Ok, jetzt habe ich nämlich nochmal kurz bei NetApplications nachgeschaut, das ist natürlich so ein bisschen Pi mal Daumen, weil das ja, ihr wisst was es ist, NetApplications, das sind die, die diese Browser-Market-Share-Geschichten machen, die also sozusagen die Webstats einsammeln. Das hat jetzt nichts mit Sales zu tun, sondern was so real geklickt wird. Aber das sind schon mal ganz interessante Zahlen. Hier steht übrigens, dass der Market-Share von Windows XP liegt, also laut NetApplications, bei 68,67%, also knapp 70% aller Büchsen da draußen, die das Internet benutzen, sind Windows Büchsen, also Windows XP Büchsen, und Vista hat 18,3%. Wie lange gibt es die Vista jetzt schon? Eineinhalb Jahre?
Die haben das echt verkackt.
Nur als Leopard.
Kein Home Run. Kann man nicht sagen.
So, und jetzt die anderen Zahlen für?
Macintel sind 5,8%. Also wenn jetzt nur 5% aller dieser Vista-Installationen 64-Bit sind, das ist ja nüscht. Das sind ja gerade mal 3,6. Nee, Quatsch. Weniger.
20. von diesen 20.
Das müsste man jetzt 1,8, 0,9. Das ist ja gerade mal ein Prozent.
Nicht mal, ja.
Jetzt suche ich mal raus, wie viel es ist.
Das heißt, es gibt locker 5-mal so viele Mac OS X 64-Bit-Installationen, wie es Vista 64-Bit-Installationen gibt.
Krass.
Aber das ist auch so ein bisschen Äpfel und Orangen miteinander vergleichen. Das bringt uns eh nicht weiter. Tatsache ist, dass sie das mit dem 64-Bit irgendwie im Griff haben und ich glaube, das wird bei Windows noch richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig lange dauern, bis da davon gesprochen werden kann, dass die Mehrheit aller Systeme unter 64-Bit läuft.
Nein, und sie haben eben genau dieses H&I-Problem. Sie haben eben dieses, es gibt diese Treiber nach wie vor nicht so wirklich, weil du hast die, weil die gibt es eben alle für 32-Bit und die sind...
Hab ich ja vorhin gesagt, da hat der mir gesagt, Tim, Windows interessiert ja nicht.
Das stimmt, also lassen wir das Thema. Kommen wir doch lieber auf die schönen, tollen Features, die hier versprochen wurden für Schnee-Leo.
Nee, warte, ich will noch ein bisschen bei der Hardware bleiben. Doch, und zwar habe ich mal noch ein bisschen geguckt bei den neuen MacBook Pros, auch wenn dir die nicht gefallen, weil die gelaserten Löcher der Lautsprecher nicht so toll finden. Aber es gibt ja als Option, kann man sich ja zum Beispiel die 2,8 GHz-CPU dazu klicken für 300 Dollar, in Euro weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau, habt ihr ja auch gesehen?
Ich hab die Pause nicht.
Kann man irgendwie so upgraden. Aber der Unterschied ist nämlich, dass der 2,53 GHz Prozessor, der ist in einer 25 Watt Verbrauchsklasse und da geht der Lüfter fast überhaupt gar nicht mehr an, auch beim Laden nicht mehr und so. Und diese 2,8 GHz CPU hat aber noch die alte Verbrauchsklasse von 35 Watt und da wird es wesentlich wärmer und dürfte auch die Batterie nicht so lange halten. Also wer wirklich sich den Schoß nicht verbrennen will und ein schön, sehr leises, sehr ruhiges Laptop haben will, der sollte halt nicht auf 2,8 aufrüsten.
Also die CT hat ja die neuen MacBooks und MacBooks Pros bis auf das Display in allerhöchsten Tönen gelobt, gerade was den Stromverbrauch angeht und die Wärme.
Die Lüftergeschwindigkeit. Ich weiß nicht so genau, aber irgendwie ist der aus, wohl im normalen Zustand.
Du hast das ja auch so gehört.
Stunde unter Volllast betreiben, das MacBook, damit er überhaupt mal auf die Idee kommt, den Lüfter anzuschmeißen und im normalen Betrieb unter 15 Watt verbraucht der Prozessor, glaube ich. Also noch weit entfernt von diesen 25.
Das passt ja damit überein, dass die Batterie in den neueren Geräten kleiner ist als in den alten, obwohl es mit 5 Stunden eigentlich ein Stück länger hält. Das ist ja nur noch 45 Wattstunden an Größe die Batterie. Vorher waren es 60 oder 55 oder so.
Aber auch genau, das ist die um 10 Wattstunden kleiner. Aber auch das nur unter Mac OS X und nicht unter Vista.
Habt ihr das eigentlich schon mal in der Hand gehabt?
Ich hab das Macbook jetzt mal beim Händler in der Hand gehabt. Ich find's sehr, sehr schick. Ich würde gern mal bei Macbook Pro die Tastatur ausprobieren, also ich find die Macbook-Tastatur schon angenehm. Ich hab mal ja das kleine Macbook gehabt.
Das sind sowieso identisch diese Geräte. Das ist nur schwerer, das Macbook Pro. Und hat diesen komischen Grill.
Also ich hoffe mal, dass sie auch noch ein bisschen andere Tastatur einbauen oder sowas, weil die original Macbook-Tastatur, die mag ich nicht so auf Dauer. Die finde ich ist mir zu laut und so bäh. Und da mag ich doch meine schöne Macbook Pro-Tastatur lieber.
Ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen. Ich finde, die Tastatur ist echt scheiße im Vergleich zu der im Macbook. Diese Macbook-Tastatur ist einfach mal da futra und das ist die beste Entscheidung, die sie machen konnten.
Die macht Krach? Ohne Ende.
Die macht Krach, die macht wirklich Krach.
Ich finde, meine schöne Macbook, deine klappert doch. Diese Tasten, die sind wackelig. Da kannst du genau mit dem Finger drauf, ein bisschen nach links und nach rechts bewegen, die sich seitlich.
Die wackeln so ein bisschen.
Das machen die hier nicht. Die sind einfach stramm. Dennis, du kriegst gleich Mate abzug.
Ich hab ja zwei Wochen lang mit einem MacBook gearbeitet und war von der Tastatur, wo ich die vom Design her viel, viel schicker finde, die MacBook-Tastatur, war ich doch vom Tipp-Gefühl nach einer Weile eher so, da mag ich meine doch lieber.
Geschmackssache. Ich finde, die Dinger haben dadurch gewonnen. Ich finde die Tastatur ist besser, weil die auch niedriger ist. Und nicht mehr in den Bildschirm reindrückt. Wobei das Problem ist ja sowieso gegessen, dadurch, dass das ja eine Glas-Oberfläche ist. Das ist ja auch noch mal so ein Aspekt, dass man die auch mal ordentlich sauber machen kann.
Also genau, einen Kommentar muss ich noch loslassen. Gibt es ja Leute, also dieses mit dem Glossi, Quatsch, nicht Glossi, Glossi und nicht Glossi, da ist ja auch ein Glaubenskrieg.
Glossi plus Glas.
Ja, also ich bin ja auch eher so der Glossi-Fan, weil ich dieses vergraute mag ich nicht so. Das spiegelt vielleicht ab und zu, das ist okay, aber das nehme ich in Kauf. Aber womit ich irgendeinem Artikelschreiber Recht geben muss, ich glaube, das war auch sogar der heiße Artikel oder CT-Artikel, dass ja nicht nur das Bild, was ja wenn du alles weiß oder hell machst, dann wird ja das verspiegelt eigentlich überblendet, dann ist mein Bildschirm einfach heller als das, was ich da drin spiegeln könnte. Aber dass ja der Rand, der ja schwarz ist, der ist ja auch Glossi und der würde schon spiegeln und da könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass man dann immer irgendwie Sachen funkeln und Blitzen sieht am Rand, die man nicht gar nicht sehen müsste. Und das könnte ich mir schon ein bisschen störend vorstellen, aber ich finde Glossi trotzdem voll toll. Ich soll immer alle 3D-Shooter oder irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Quake 3 spielen. Das sieht einfach total super aus.
Also einen Tag nachdem wir unseren Podcast gemacht haben, als ich noch in Toronto war, kamen die Geräte dann auch tatsächlich in den Apple Store dort und dann habe ich dann irgendwie beide mal angefasst. Also ich finde ja, ich finde die Geräte sagenhaft. Also vor allem diese Verwindungssteifheit ist einfach unreal. Also sowas Stabiles habe ich in meinem Leben noch nicht in der Hand gehabt. Das ist einfach mal ein, da ist er, der Brick. Ja, das ist irgendwie, das ist einfach ein Stück, das merkt man irgendwie sofort. Das ist ja auch schon bei dem R so gewesen, das ist ja noch viel flacher, noch viel dünner und eigentlich auch genauso stabil und das schlägt bei den Maschinen einfach voll durch, das merkt man. Und das Finishing von all diesen Details ist halt einfach noch mal ganz weit weg. Also so neben so einem alten MacBook Pro, da sieht das MacBook Pro, das sieht so alt aus dagegen, das ist wirklich echt absolut.
Wie diese Main-Klinik, aber ich meine, das ist ja auch alt. Seit wieviel Jahren gibt es jetzt diesen Faktor, diesen Vorfaktor hier?
Na ja, und hast du gemerkt, dass sie wirklich fast alles korrigiert haben, was sie hier über Monate hin immer wieder beklagt haben?
Also die Festplatte ist leicht austauschbar.
Festplatte leicht austauschbar, generell stabiles Vorhäuse und dann Magnetverschluss. Magnetverschluss und das ist alles nicht so wackelig und klappert und hoffentlich ist halt auch diese Schwitzproblematik jetzt endlich mal vorbei. Also...
Meinen Kritikpunkt haben sie nicht beseitigt. Das Mikro ist immer noch da, dass man immer drauf, dass man es immer hört, wenn man auf der Tastatur rumtippt und nicht im Display drunter.
Ich hab das noch nie gebraucht.
Ach, ist das bei Macbook jetzt auch so dann?
Das ist, also ich hab...
Nee, kann's ja gar nicht sein, er hat ja gar keinen Grill.
Ich hab gar keine... Doch, der hat hier so ein ganz ganz kleines Löchlein hier oben. Also hier oben ist so ein winzig kleiner Grill und Macbook...
Wer benutzt denn dieses Mikro, mal ehrlich? Wenn man irgendwie auch nur so ein bisschen chatte, Skype oder irgendwas macht, hat man doch hier so ein USB-Headset.
Ja, aber wenn du mal keins hast, dann brauchst du das halt.
Die Sprachqualität ist eigentlich, solange man nicht rumditscht, ist die relativ okay und man kann mit einem neuen Kopfhörer, setzt man Kopfhörer dazu auf, und kann damit schön telefonieren.
Es ist klar, warum sie das Mikrofon da oben weggenommen haben, wenn ich jetzt mal drüber nachdenke.
Warum?
Weil da ein Glasdeckel drüber ist. Wie sollen sie denn das Mikrofon durch das Glas durchkriegen?
Bestimmt eigentlich.
Genau. Deswegen.
Dann hätten sie es ja vielleicht von hier oben, oder ich weiß nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall, und damit gehe ich davon aus, wobei der Helligkeit sein soll, ist das noch mal eine spannende Frage.
Ja, was ist mir noch aufgefallen? Na gut, es gibt halt jetzt so Gesten. Das ist mir so eine Software-Geschichte.
Was mit den vier Fingern auf dem Treckbett?
Ist völlig bekloppt.
Weiß ich nicht.
Das ist Gewöhnungssache.
Ich meine, das ist zwar sehr compelling. Du machst vier zu Seite, dann kommst du in den...
Exposä-Modus?
Nein, nach oben und nach unten. Das hab ich jetzt nicht genug benutzt. Aber was mir sofort aufgefallen ist, der Leo vom FSC-Karlok hat das auch gleich moniert. Du schiebst halt vier Finger nach rechts und dann kriegst du halt deinen Programmeselektor.
Dann musst du mit einem Finger wieder auswählen?
Genau, und dann musst du aber drei Finger wegnehmen, damit du darin auch weiter links nach rechts aussuchen kannst. Wäre viel cooler, wenn man mit vier Fingern einfach gleich durch die ganze Reihe durchgeht. Dann hältst du einfach eine Gesse, lässt los, genau. Also das werden sie sicherlich nochmal korrigieren.
Was ich beim Trackpad ein bisschen schade finde, ist, dass da offensichtlich doch ein Scharnier oben drin ist, im oberen Bereich.
Und dass es dann nach so abkippt.
Genau, es kappt so ein bisschen ab. Und zwar unten geht es viel leichter, oben kann man gar nicht klicken.
Ja, aber es ersetzt eine Taste, die auch schon drunter war. Also ich muss sagen, ich hab 5 Minuten drauf rumgeklickt und dann fiel mir erst auf, dass das ja jetzt ein anderes Trackpad ist.
Also intuitiv wie Sau ist es auf jeden Fall.
Also ich hab's nicht gemerkt, dass irgendwas anders ist. Ich hab mich da einfach rangesetzt, hab rumgeklickt, hab erstmal auf ein paar ganz andere Sachen geachtet und dann kam ich irgendwann auf, ach ja, das Trackpad war ja auch noch anders. Huch, ich hab ja schon geklickt. Also ich hatte keinerlei Umstellungsprobleme. Und ich finde das funktioniert auch ganz prima. Auch wenn es halt wirklich, ich hab jetzt ein paar Berichte schon gelesen, wo Leute so Issues hatten, mit dem was ich so meinte, wo ihr nicht so richtig drüber reden wolltet, mit wenn denn der Finger auf dem Trackpad ist und du klickst damit und so. Also das ist mit den Gesten, da kommt man irgendwie, gibt es wohl doch noch Situationen, wo du hintereinander kommst.
Ich bin ja auch kein Fan von dem, man kann ja auch jetzt mit dem Trackpad schon einschalten, dass man da drüber so klicken kann, aber ich schalte es nun aus, weil ich dann immer durcheinander komme, weil ich so mit dem Finger drüber schwebe. Aber da ist es ja doch ein mechanischer Klick, deswegen könnte es noch mal was anderes sein. Aber ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ja, ja, es ist gut. Ich hab auch festgestellt, dass ich doch nicht immer mit Tab klicke.
Und ich hab festgestellt, dass ich die Funktion doch eingeschaltet habe. Mit diesem Tab.
Mein Gott, das ist ja ein Podcast der Leuterung.
Das Outings.
Ja, das ist ja schon fast. Wir sollten ja eigentlich noch so einen schwarzen Mollton um uns herum machen, damit das auch so dieses I-Confess...
Wir könnten nachher auch noch alle eine Kerze anzünden.
Oh Steve, erhöre mich, ich habe gesündigt. Ich habe geklickt. Letztes Hardware-Detail, was ich hier noch auf meiner Liste habe, und dann müssen wir noch mal kurz auf Snow Leopard kommen. Die MacBook Pros und ich glaube auch das MacBook haben die Möglichkeit, auf einem der beiden USB-Ports, und zwar wahlweise, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, also wer auch immer das als erstes anfordert, einen Ampere Strom zu liefern. Anstatt einem halben, wie der USB-Standard...
Wo hast du das gelesen?
Diese URL habe ich mir leider nicht notiert. Ich bin untröstlich. Aber...
Mit anderen Worten, dass 2,5 Zoll Festplatten jetzt ganz offiziell darüber laufen.
Ob es offiziell ist, ist noch so eine Frage.
Ja, es war... Ich hoffe, dass ich da noch den Link finde. Habe ich mir irgendwie nicht gemerkt. Heißt aber, dass sozusagen das MacBook und MacBook Pro gegenüber einem iPhone mit dem Netzteil gleich zieht. Weil derzeit lädt das Netzteil schon mit einem Ampere. Aber ein MacBook lädt das iPhone auch nicht nur im Ansatz so schnell wie das Netzteil. Und jetzt kannst du einfach dein iPhone dann an deinem Rechner dranlassen und es kann theoretisch halt voll...
Genauso schnell laden wie...
Wie am Netzteil. Das ist schon ein wichtiger Punkt. Wie sich das mit den Festplatten auswirkt, weiß ich nicht.
Also mit den Festplatten ist ja ein bekanntes Phänomen, dass die früher an den iBooks, also an den noch PPC-Rechnern immer nicht so ganz anfahren wollten, weil die 2,5 Zoll Festplatten zum Anfahren irgendwie relativ viel Strom brauchen. Und denen konnten die meisten USB-Ausgänge damals nicht liefern, bzw. die an den Macs.
Ist doch heute noch so.
Und ich glaube, mit den Macbooks ist es besser geworden. Aber vielleicht ist das dann so, dass die dann offiziell die ganze Zeit über den Strom liefern können. Das wär jetzt so meine Vermutung, dass das auch viel mehr als nur für das iPhone taugt.
Das ist übrigens noch ein Kritikpunkt am iPhone, den ich hab. Wenn es mal so richtig leer ist und auch schon ausging, und du willst jetzt telefonieren, dann kannst du es ans Netzteil anschließen, kannst starten, und das passiert erstmal 5 Minuten lang nichts, weil er irgendwie zu leer ist. Dann kannst du 5 Minuten lang nicht telefonieren, obwohl du ein Netzteil dran hast. Das find ich ganz schön schlecht, weil... 5 Minuten? Stell dir vor, mein Haus brennt ja, und ich muss unbedingt die Feuerwehr anrufen, dann geht das nicht, obwohl ich Strom dran hab.
Aber wenn dein Haus brennt, hast du eh keinen Strom dran hängen.
Klar, man.
Dann stehst du vor dem Haus, also eh keinen Strom.
Wenn ich noch in der Bude bin, oder willst du schnell telefonieren? Ist doch egal, was der Grund ist, aber du hast dein Netz da dran und kannst trotzdem nicht telefonieren. Das find ich ganz schön scharf.
Sorgt dafür, dass dein Akku nicht leer ist.
Das ist wirklich leichter gesagt als getan.
Apple macht lieber erst mal vorher ein paar andere Dinge, bevor ihr euch um so Dennis-Probleme kümmert.
Ja, aber telefonieren, finde ich, sollte schon irgendwie die erste Priorität bei diesem Gerät sein.
Weißt du was? Ich glaube, es wird einen Grund geben dafür.
Das ist mir egal, es soll gehen.
Na ja gut, wie auch immer. Können wir nochmal auf die Hardware zurückkommen?
Ich dachte, Snowlappart kommt jetzt.
Ich hab doch noch was gefunden. Ja, ihr habt mich total durcheinander gemacht. Vorhin wollte ich über Schnee-Leo zu Ende reden, aber dann ist er wieder gekommen und hat wieder alles durcheinander gemacht. Weißt du?
Was hast du denn da für ein lustiges kleines Hardware-Detail?
Irgendwas hast du gesagt. Ich wollte nochmal diesen Display-Port Revisited, weil das ist ja nun wirklich die umstrittenste Schnittstelle und auch das einzige, wo ich sagen würde, wenn man jetzt mal von der Firewire-Problematik absieht, wo Leute jetzt so ein Upgrade-Problem haben.
Wegen Display-Port.
Es ist auf jeden Fall so ein Systemwechsel, der recht einschneidend sein kann.
Welcher Adapter ist bei den Geräten dabei? Keiner.
Keiner?
Keiner. Also der auf DVI kostet 30 Dollar oder Euro.
Der auf VGA auch.
Und der auf Dual Link für so einen 30 Zoller kostet 100.
Und der steckt auch nochmal am USB dran, weil der braucht Saft. Da ist richtig Elektronik im Spiel, da ist richtig Logik am Start.
Und von Mini Display-Port auf Normal Display-Port?
Gibt's noch gar nicht? Nö, aber ich hab ehrlich gesagt wenig Zweifel, dass das schnell kommen wird. Abgesehen davon Normal Display-Port, Bildschirme gibt's, glaub ich, irgendwie zwei oder drei. Der hält halt so ein Ding.
HDMI wär natürlich noch interessant, um es an den Fernseher anzuschließen.
Das geht ja.
Das geht? Display-Port auf HDMI-Adapter?
Nein, auf DVI.
Ach, und DVI, dann brauch ich noch von DVI wieder auf HDMI.
Ja, aber das ist ja nur ein Stecker. Also DVI und HDMI ist dasselbe Signal. HDMI ist bloß DVI plus...
Nochmal Verschlüsselung, ne?
Nee, das hat damit erstmal nichts zu tun, sondern es ist Strom, Steuersignale und Audio geht ja auch noch über HDMI theoretisch, das ist ja so ein integrierter... HDMI ist ja so ein bisschen so das moderne Skat.
Und haben die nicht sogar noch irgendwie...
Aber Displayport ist auch mit Audio.
Ja, die haben DRM mit drin, das hat übrigens auch Displayport.
Displayport hat auch DRM, aber DVI hat auch DRM, oder?
Nee, noch nicht. Sie können, aber sie haben es noch nicht.
Ja, das HDMI bezieht sich auf die Verwendung mit dem... Also das HDCP bezieht sich auf... Ich weiß nicht genau, worauf es sich bezieht. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man HDCP anwenden kann mit DVI-Only oder ob das irgendwelche von diesen Leitungen dort verwendet. Ich weiß nur, dass das eh nicht in unserer Welt drin steckt.
Ok, also es ist kompatibel. Ich wollte nämlich immer mal rauskriegen, was eigentlich der Unterricht...
Also du wirst auf jeden Fall, wenn du jetzt ein neues MacBook haust mit Mini Displayport, dann kannst du da einen auf DVI-Adapter anschließen und auf diesen DVI-Adapter kannst du einen auf HDMI-Stecker machen. Das ist ja nur so ein kleiner Adapter, das ist bei Media Markt an der Kasse. Dein Audio war da noch nie drin.
Na doch, über Displayport geht ja auch Audio, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Über Displayport geht theoretisch auch Audio. Praktisch geht da meines Wissens bisher kein Audio raus.
Na doch, weil die neuen Monitore von Apple haben ja Lautsprecher unten mit drin.
Ja, ich hab das hinterfragt im Apple Store und hab halt mich mit so einem Mitarbeiter dort unterhalten und der hat auch augenfällig sofort verstanden, was ich meinte.
Er hat den USB-Checker rausgezogen und die Musik hat aufgehört.
Das haben wir nicht ausprobiert. Diese Epistore sind ja immer wahnsinnig überlaufen und überfüllt und du bist echt froh, wenn du da raus bist. Aber er meinte mit Nachdruck, das sei ganz sicher so, dass das über USB geht. Also die Kamera und der Sound läuft über USB. Until proven otherwise. Ich hab's jetzt nicht selber ausprobiert, aber das war seine doch sehr, wie soll ich sagen?
Also er macht den Eindruck, als ob er sich absolut sicher sei.
Er machte wirklich den Eindruck, als hätte er verstanden, wovon ich rede. Es ist jetzt auch so, ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, die Kamera, was die für einen Datenstrom liefert. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Kamera über USB 1 gar nicht funktionieren könnte. Und die derzeitige Spezifikation von DisplayPort sieht ja nur ein Megabit auf dem Nebenkanal, Rückkanal vor. Das heißt, du kannst damit gar kein USB 2...
Ja, jetzt weißt du aber nicht, dass das Audio über den DisplayPort in USB eingepackt sein muss.
Nein, das Audio nicht, aber wenn schon die Kamera nicht da drin sein kann, warum sollten sie dann das Audio darüber...
Da kann man jetzt noch eine Frage, wie draufkriegen.
Wie auch immer. Offensichtlich ist dem nicht so. Und wir werden das sicherlich auch bald noch mal bestätigt bekommen. Tatsache ist, dass DisplayPort schon nach außen hin zu allem eigentlich kompatibel ist, was heute da ist. Nur, wenn du jetzt einen Bildschirm hast mit DisplayPort, dann und nur mit DisplayPort, dann wird es halt knifflig mit alten Geräten. Weil du kannst eben nicht einen DVI-Ausgang oder VGA-Ausgang ohne weiteres auf DisplayPort bringen. Weil das ist ja auch nicht so, dass diese Adapter, die wandeln ja nicht das DisplayPort in VGA, sondern das DisplayPort-Signal liefert zusätzlich noch ein VGA-Signal. Auf dem Stecker sind halt die Pins drin und der Stein, der liefert das. Natürlich liefern sie also noch etwas DVI-kompatibles und sie liefern auch noch etwas VGA-kompatibles, weil sie sich das heutzutage noch nicht schenken können. Aber sie liefern nichts mehr mit Video.
Das sieht man ja immer beim DVI-Ausgang.
Deswegen gibt es das eben auch nicht mehr. Und in der fernen Zukunft irgendwann könnte auch ein Display-Port auch das nicht mehr liefern, wenn sie der Meinung sind, das wäre OPPO-2. Wobei das wahrscheinlich nicht so schnell passieren. Aber andersherum geht es halt nicht. Du kannst halt nicht ein Display-Port-Signal nehmen und in irgendwas anderes übersetzen, so ohne weiteres.
Und du kannst vor allen Dingen nicht ein DVI-A-Signal einfach mal eben Display-Port übersetzen.
Genau, also es ginge, wenn du halt so eine aufwändige Box machst. Aber das kann durchaus sein. Also muss man mal schauen, wie sich das entwickelt. Warum Display-Port und dass es breite Unterstützung hat, naja, ich denke, da gibt es schon viele gute Argumente. Man muss halt schauen, damit der Markt macht, die Apple da jetzt an den Tag legt, wird es sicherlich nicht lange dauern. Sie haben halt jetzt den ersten großen Schritt gewagt, wie seinerzeit mit USB auch. Und warum man das will, ist natürlich auch klar. Also, sie zahlen halt einfach nicht mehr so viel Lizenzabgaben. Also HDMI wäre richtig teuer mit Lizenzen. Und DisplayPort ist einfach mal royalty-free. Das ist halt so ein Standard. Der wird von Intel und von allen anderen PC-Herstellern auch weitgehend unterstützt. Also wir werden das jetzt sehen, dass DisplayPort überall Einzug hält.
Also ich gehe mal ein bisschen davon aus, dass es so ein Fall mit diesem DisplayPort ist, so wie damals, als sie USB eingeführt haben, haben sie auch alle geschrien. Und jetzt mittlerweile kreiert kein Hahn mehr nach. Und das wird bei DisplayPort wahrscheinlich noch viel, viel schneller gehen.
Mal gucken. Naja, wo die Hähne immer noch krennen, wo ich auch gerne noch ein bisschen mitgackern möchte, ist die Sache mit dem Firewire. Da gab es dann jetzt hier so eine Meldung, ich glaube, das ging irgendwie über MacNodes. Die erste Meldung so, oh ja, es gibt ja einen Standard, der heißt 1394C. Genau, die Geschichte, in der halt drin steht, wie man Firewire eben über Cat 5 machen könnte.
Also über Ethernet-Kabel quasi.
Naja, genau, da fängt nämlich diese Konfusion an.
Über das Kabel, nicht über die Karte.
Ethernet-Kabel, sagen wir mal einen Cat 5-Kabel. Was man auch für Ethernet verwendet.
Und für ESDN.
Oder?
Also Cat 5-Kabel für ESDN ist eher selten, sondern du benutzt RJ45, du benutzt denselben Stecker, aber du benutzt in der Regel kein Cat 5-Kabel für ESDN.
Man kann aber ein Ethernet-Kabel mal eben reinschalten.
Du kannst das nehmen, aber in der Regel sind, wenn du jetzt ein ESDN-Telefon kaufst, dann ist da kein achtpoliges Kabel dran, sondern hast ein vierpoliges Kabel dran.
Ja, aber wenn man bei seiner Fritzbox versehentlich das falsche Kabel in den ESDN-Box steckt, ist das auch okay.
Wenn man bei seiner Fritzbox ein bisschen mehr Voltage bei ESDN rauskommt, dann ist deine Box im Arsch.
Nee, ich meine, wenn ich einfach das falsche Kabel verwende.
Er redet nur vom Kabel. Du kannst natürlich überall da auch Cut-5-Kabel nehmen.
Also auf jeden Fall.
In den Firmen haben sie natürlich nur noch Cut-5 verlegt und da patchen natürlich ESDN dann darüber. Deswegen hast du es schon.
Genau. Auf jeden Fall war jetzt diese Vermutung, dieses so, vielleicht lassen sie ja Firewire jetzt den Stecker weg, aber behalten irgendwie Firewire nach wie vor und machen das jetzt über den Cut-5-Port. Da gingen dann irgendwie viele hin und her. Ich habe mir jetzt nicht jeden Artikel darüber durchgelesen, aber ich habe mir mal kurz Gedanken darüber gemacht und vor allem habe ich mir mal kurz dieses Paper angeschaut, bzw. kein Paper, sondern so eine Introduction zu diesem Standard und da stehen ein paar Sachen drin, die man mal hier auch klar sagen sollte. Also es handelt sich dabei nicht um ein Firewire über Ethernet.
Standard.
Genau, das ist es nicht, sondern es handelt sich um Firewire über Cat 5, was man dann wahrscheinlich auch über eine RJ45-Buchse rausgeben könnte. Es gab so bei manchen die Hoffnung, na ja, haben wir ja schon. Man könnte ja jetzt den Firewire-Stein trotzdem wieder einbauen in den Computer, also das MacBook hat meiner Meinung nach keinen, aber könnte man ja theoretisch machen und dann eben über Cat 5 anschließen.
Dann könnte man aber genauso gut einfach noch einen zusätzlichen Platz in das Gehäuse fräsen, vermutlich.
Ja, na gut, man würde sich den Platz sparen, aber man würde sich halt das Silikon nicht sparen und man würde sich auch nicht diese Problematik ersparen, dass man ja mit Firewire auch noch viel Strom liefern muss. Irgendwie 1,5 Ampere Strom. Das wäre halt da immer noch alles das Gleiche. Und vor allem, was ist, wenn du Ethernet hast, dann hast du kein Firewire und du musst es dann irgendwie auch umstecken.
Ja, die haben ja doch was spekuliert von gleichzeitigem, was weiß ich nicht alles.
Das glaube ich halt auch.
Auf keinen Fall, dass Apple sowas einbauen würde, weil das bedeutet, dass irgendwie deine Schnittstelle mal so und mal so sein kann. Mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du dir entweder dein Switch oder dein Firewire-Device wegbrätst. Also das... Ich sehe das nicht kommen. Das ist sicherlich für bestimmte Firewire- Infrastrukturen interessant, dass es auch noch diese Variante gibt. Aber du brauchst ja dann auf der anderen Seite auch etwas, was Cat 5 wieder entgegennimmt.
Das heißt, man bräuchte auch komplett neue Firewire auf... Cat 5 Firewire auf Firewire klassisch Kabeladapter.
Genau, also es wäre wahrscheinlich, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es schon kompatibel mit Firewire 800. Es wäre vorstellbar, dass man auf der einen Seite RJ45-Stecker hat und auf der anderen Seite ein Firewire 800, wenn es wirklich dasselbe ist. Bin ich mir aber jetzt nicht so ganz sicher, aber es kann ja auch sein, weil ein Cat 5 Kabel eben anders ist, als die Spezifikation eines Firewire-Kabels, dass es dann eben sich physikalisch auch noch unterscheidet. Dann ginge das auch nicht. Dann bräuchtest du einen Firewire-Hub, der Cat 5 als Eingang hat und entsprechende Standard Firewire-Schnittstellen verteilt oder einen Switch.
Also ich glaube, wir können davon ausgehen, dass das nicht passieren wird, oder?
Ich wäre da auch sehr überrascht. Ich denke, Sie haben es einfach weggelassen, weil Sie der Meinung sind, es wäre jetzt mal vorbei. Und da haben Sie wahrscheinlich nicht ganz unrecht und es ist schade für die Leute, die jetzt noch viele Firewire-Devices benutzen, mich eingeschlossen. Aber man muss jetzt mal sehen, wie sich der Markt da entwickelt. Vielleicht war das ein bisschen zu früh. Das wird dann die Zeit.
Welche Geräte kann man denn, was ist denn eigentlich noch, was muss man eigentlich noch immer noch über Firewire einschließen? Audio Equipment. Also bei Audio hat es mich jetzt wirklich mal, ich weiß nicht, ob von euch jemand diesen neuen Spreeblick-Podcast hört, den ich mit Malte seit ein paar Wochen mache.
Ich hab ihn schon auf meinem Pod, aber ich bin noch nicht dazu gekommen.
Und das ist, technisch ist das so helle kompliziert und versage ich im Augenblick so unglaublich komplett. Und zwar alles wegen scheiß USB, wegen dieser dämlichen Latenzen und weiss der Teufel was.
Weil ihr Skype macht.
Nee, wir machen keinen Skype. Wir haben zwei USB-Headsets an einem MacBook Pro dran und die laufen auseinander von der Latenz her im Laufe der Zeit. Wir haben das Problem, dass wenn ich ein, womit ich nie gerechnet hätte, man schließt einen USB-Hub an, weil wir wollten auch mal drei Headsets dran haben. Weil MacBook Pro hat ja dämlicherweise nur zwei USB-Eingänge. Und dann habe ich einen USB-Hub dazwischen gehangen und da noch zwei Headsets dran gehangen. Und auch wenn nur ein Headset dran hängt, es kommt nichts mehr an. Das ist komplett tot. Es ist als ob, also ich dachte es wäre digitales Signal rein, digitales Signal raus, dass da gar nichts dran gemacht wird. Das hat nichts mehr mit dem zu tun. Man hört, dass irgendwelche Geräusche da sind, die klingen wie irgendeine Signale.
Ist es eventuell, dass der Hub irgendwie nur USB 1 ist und du machst USB 2 oder andersrum?
Das ist definitiv ein USB 2 Hub. Ich kann mir eher den umgekehrten Weg vorstellen, dass das vielleicht USB 1-1 Geräte sind.
Die Mikrofone sind eigentlich alle USB 1.
Und dass er das nicht so richtig auf die Reihe kriegt mit einem Timing von USB 1. Ich probiere jetzt nochmal irgendwo einen alten USB 1.
Furchtbar, ich dachte das wäre ein Problem. Ich kann dir sagen, digital audio sucks big time. Das ist wirklich, da läuft auf einmal so viel an, das ist auch der Grund, warum ich hier wieder komplett in meinem Recording Setup wieder auf analog zurückgegangen bin. Das ist einfach auf eine gewisse Art und Weise beherrschbar. Man verspricht sich da eine Menge von digital audio, aber man muss die Sache wirklich sehr im Griff haben. Das ist auch der Grund, warum es immer noch so viel Ärger gibt mit diesen ganzen Sachen. Timing ist das Hauptproblem. Das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum ich nicht sehe, dass das eben mal so eben im Profi- oder Semi-Pro-Bereich auf USB geht. Firewire ist an der Stelle zumindest so weit abgehangen, dass man jetzt weiß, womit man dealt.
Kriegst du deine Clock mit einfach oder wie ist das?
Genau. Also erst mal kannst du da relativ flexibel konfigurieren, wer die Clock providet und so weiter. Das ist schon mal so eine ganz wichtige Sache. Du hast ja auch bei Firewire so ein nicht hierarchisches System. Das ist ja so peer-to-peer. Jedes Device ist irgendwie gleich. Deswegen ist Firewire auch so teuer. Deswegen ist Firewire so aufwendig. Deswegen meiden das eben viele auch für einfache Geräte.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich so toll.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich so toll. Deswegen gibt es auch eigentlich so recht keine Alternative dazu. Ich sehe nicht, dass USB in absehbarer Zeit da irgendwas ändert.
Also sowas wie der Target-Modus, mit dem man mal eben zwischen seine Daten, seinen MacBook als externe Festplatte an seinen anderen Rechner anschließen kann. Kann man mit USB nicht hinkriegen.
Also bei Digital Audio ist das besonders frustrierend. Ansonsten braucht man es eigentlich nur noch für Leute, die noch Festplatten haben. Also wenn du wirklich Highspeed und RAID anschließen willst an deinen Rechner.
Na und für Videoschnitt mit Mini-DV und so.
Naja, das ist nicht mehr so. Also im Profibereich hatten wir auch schon letztes Mal glaube ich schon drüber geredet, oder?
Haben wir da? Ich weiß nicht, ob wir auch noch mehr drüber geredet haben.
Es geht halt weg davon.
Die Kameras haben halt Festplatten.
Die Kameras haben Festplatten.
Film komplett.
Flash. Dieses Realtime, ich meine du willst nicht 5 Stunden Videomaterial aufnehmen und dann nochmal 5 Stunden damit verbringen, das auf deinen Computer zu laden. Sondern du willst das irgendwie über eine High-Speed-Schnittstelle anschließen und rüber kopieren, was du brauchst und dann lästest du drauf.
Ja, es gibt so nicht so richtig Standards. Also läuft das dann quasi so, dass man...
Doch, es gibt Standards. Heißt USB-Festplatte.
Also so wie bei einer Digitalkamera, dass du dann hast einfach ein Datalsystem da drauf, fertig und dann ist das ein F32 oder wahrscheinlich kein F32, weil damit hätte man ja wahrscheinlich heulische Probleme.
Was auch immer.
Whatever. Und dann kopiert man die Daten rüber und dann hat sich der Salat. Und davon gibt es schon genug Geräte. Ich hab sowas noch nicht gesehen.
Was heißt genug? Es gibt natürlich noch eine Menge Leute, die mit Firewire-Devices leben und die kotzen, weil sie sich vielleicht gerade mal einen neuen Rechner gerne kaufen wollen würden.
Und wenn ich jetzt in den Mediamarkt gehen würde und da im 200, 300 Euro Bereich eine Videokamera mir kaufen würde, hätten die doch wahrscheinlich auch noch die meisten TV und Firewire.
Ich meine, seit zwei Jahren hätten die alle nur noch USB. Ich habe es jetzt nicht überprüft.
Ich habe es auch nicht überprüft.
Aber es ist schon so, das Firewire ist definitiv auf dem Rückzug, was den Markt betrifft, bei Festplatten auch und bleibt halt nur noch Audio. Und jetzt kann man sagen, Audio ist pro. Kann man so sagen.
Oder sagen wir im Echtzeitbereich.
Aber für schnelle Festplatten, ich weiß nicht. Wir drehen uns da jetzt auch im Kreis in der Diskussion. Ja, nochmal zum Schnee-Leo. Nochmal der Nachtrag, weil du hast ja vorhin schon erwähnt, irgendwie Feinder in Coco.
Genau.
Soll endlich kommen. Hurra, sag ich nur. Ist aber jetzt auch absehbar, weil es eben im Rahmen der 64-Bit-Umstellung nötigt sich ja Apple selbst sozusagen das zu machen.
Wie sieht denn das eigentlich in dem Zusammenhang auch? Das haben wir damals darüber spekuliert. Aber wenn dann alle Visible Applications Coco 64-Bit sein sollen, und das Snow Leopard müsste ja eigentlich auch iTunes, ist iTunes mittlerweile eigentlich Coco oder ist das noch Carbon?
Carbon. Haben sie komische Häuser auch nicht mit aufgelistet, ne?
Ich glaub bei iTunes wird es auch noch lange dauern, weil es läuft ja auch unter Windows.
Also ist iTunes dann quasi nicht offizieller Teil von Snow Leopard in dem Sinne?
Mich fände ich überraschend, wenn iTunes das Programm bei Apple ist, was am wenigsten Funktion des Betriebssystems nutzt. Das ist schon immer so ein bisschen die Sau gewesen, die als erste durchs Dorf getrieben wurde, um mal zu gucken, wie die Reaktion ist. Ich sag nur User Interfaces, hier Metal Look und diese ganzen Sachen. Das kam immer alles irgendwie über iTunes. Da wird immer alles reingeworfen.
Ich meine, wenn man weiß, woher iTunes so langsam stammt, aus welchem Programm das geboren worden ist, dann...
War es nicht dieses Soundtrack?
Genau, von Cassandry & Green?
Cassidy & Green.
Das war ja auch damals schon unglaublich hässliches Programm.
Was?
Das war das totale Rollmodel. Das war eine der am sauersten entwickelten Mac OS UIs, die ich gesehen hatte. Das war schön parallelisiert, alles lief alles flüssig.
Also es gab damals Audion, das war Seamable ohne Ende und die Seams waren alle hässlich.
Was war Seamable? Soundjam? Nein.
So wechsle ich das jetzt?
Ja, mit Audion.
Nee, die waren da gegeneinander.
Soundjam war so eine richtige Mac-Applikation.
Soundjam-MP, genau.
Mal gucken. Na, das sieht mir aber nicht nach richtiger Mac-Applikation aus, dieser Screenshot. Was?
Was sieht denn da nicht nach Mac-Applikation aus?
Das ist Quicktime-Pseudo. Was? Das war schon, die hatten ganz furchtbar hässliches Seam.
Für solche Controls gab es damals noch gar keine Standards. Was ich meine, ist die ganze Art und Weise, wie Fensterresizing funktioniert hat und so weiter. Da gab es ganz andere schlimme Beispiele. Aber es ist doch auch egal, wir sind doch bei 64 Bit und Schnee-Leopard, oder? So, und das können wir jetzt auch einfach mal zumachen. Es ist einfach absehbar, dass hier jetzt alle Applikationen, die noch Carbon sind. Ich weiß nicht, hast du da mal eine Liste gesehen, Dennis? Was das alles noch umfasst, außer dem Finder?
Nein.
Oder fällt dir sonst noch irgendwas ein, was hier so stand? Also meine, klar, ihre ganze Final Cut! Aber jetzt, was mit dem OS kommt? Das können so viele nicht sein. Naja, auf jeden Fall werden sie das halt einfach machen, eben um diesen Speed Gain zu machen. Was sie jetzt auch noch angekündigt haben, oder was, ne, angekündigt haben sie es nicht, sondern was jetzt durchgesickert ist, ist ein Feature, das nennt sich Image Boot. Na, das heißt, dass man jetzt von einem Image booten kann.
Da muss man erst mal zu erzählen, dass man ja pro Filesystem, oder besser gesagt, pro Partition kann man bisher nur ein OS installieren. Also kannst du auf deiner Platte drei Partitionen machen und dann pro Partition einen 10.4, 10.5 und Snow Leopard installieren. Aber mehr auch nicht. Und mit diesen Images könnte man mehrere OS innerhalb eines, also ein OS in ein Image legen und aber mehrere Image auf ein Filesystem. Und dann könnte man über das Boot-Menü auswählen, dann müssten die aber auch erstmal ein Firmware-Update rausschieben.
Also mit...
Wer muss ein Firmware-Update rausschieben?
Na, Apfel.
Stimmt.
Also mit Images meint jetzt tatsächlich diese DMG-Datei, die man gerne zum Download von Oder sie nutzen den die gleiche Boot-Firmware, also des EFI-Dingens, der erstmal noch so einen Zwischenbooter lädt und der macht das dann. Da müssen sie kein Firmware-Update raustun.
Oder sie haben schon alles drin dafür. Das finde ich auf jeden Fall super, weil das löst doch eine ganze Menge Probleme wieder.
Das hilft beim Virtualisieren dann, oder?
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine schicke Sache. Also für eben mal schnell was anderes booten, ist das eine geile Sache. Man könnte sich immer so ein kleines 10.4 oder 10.5 rumliegen lassen und mal eben was testen, ohne dass man dafür eine Partition freihalten muss. Das nervt mich eigentlich, dieses blöde Partitionieren. Das würde dann wegfallen. Die zweite Sache, die noch angekündigt wurde oder verraten wurde war...
FS plus compression.
Genau, und da bin ich ja ein bisschen ins Grübeln gekommen.
Ja, weil da stand auch, dass es dann auch unter 10.4 funktionieren soll.
Exakt, genau da kam ich auch ins Grübeln.
Nicht funktionieren soll, sondern ohne das Dateisystem zu zerschießen und ohne die Dateien zu zerschießen.
Ja, einen Weg, dass es da auch noch geht. Aber es war ja schon explizit von Systemdateien, die Rede, die read-only sind.
Ich glaube auch, dass einfach nur die Bundles irgendwie so auch als Image daherkommen, die wiederum compressed sind, dass es mit dem Filesystem selbst gar nichts zu tun hat.
Was?
Wie?
Na, du hast ja jetzt ein Programm zum Beispiel, besteht ja aus einem Ordner, also Bundle nennen die das ja, und da drin hast du halt deine ganzen Files, das GUI, das Executable und Info-P-List und Icons und Zeug. Und wenn du da draus so ein Disk-Image machst, was ja, kann man ja Compression einschalten, dann wäre das ja schon eine Art Komprimierung, die ist dann nicht auf Filesystem-Ebene, sondern halt mehr auf...
Ach du meinst, dass sie Slash-System als System.dmg installieren oder alles?
Naja System nicht, aber zum Beispiel, Kext ist ja auch eigentlich ein Ordner. Und dann könnte man alle Kexts in so Disk-Images packen oder... Weiß nicht auf welcher...
Ja, aber da hast du immer noch HFS da drin.
Aber kombiniert das auf der DMG-Ebene, aber ich glaube ich auch nicht so richtig dran, ich nehme an...
Ja, aber es hieß auch, es sei explizit für Read-Only-Datei.
Ja klar, weil du danach ja auch nicht mehr drin schreiben kannst. Da müsste man das DMG ja zurückschreiben, das Gesamte immer.
Also ich vermute mal, dass das für solche Sachen sein wird, wie zum Beispiel, wenn man sich so ein Programm installiert, so ein Mac OS X, dann hat man immer unglaublich viele Sprachen dabei, wenn man sich die Kiste erstmal kauft. Das Allererste, was ich immer erstmal mache, ist die ganzen Sprachen, die ich nicht brauche, löschen.
Das kannst du jetzt nicht mehr machen.
Unglaublich viel kann ich jetzt nicht mehr machen, wieso nicht?
Wegen der Signierung.
Ich hab's immer noch gemacht, ich weiß gar nicht, habe ich's gemacht.
Aber dann hast du halt das Problem, dass dann deine Signatur bricht.
Dass dann die Signatur gebrochen ist.
Was vielleicht normalerweise kein Problem ist, sondern dann hast du dieses Problem, dass das Programm nicht mehr für Keychain zugreifen kann.
Was auf jeden Fall immer noch besteht, ist so dieses, dass Programme relativ viel Platz auf der Platte wegnehmen, einfach wegen Sprachen, die ich im Allgemeinen eh nicht brauche. Und dass, wenn sowas von vornherein mitkomprimiert wäre, wär ja nur praktisch.
Na gut, ich mein, das ist ja nun schon seit Langem klar, dass sie alles sehr viel kleiner kriegen. Und Dennis hat ja auch schon mal berichtet, dass da eigentlich nur dieser eine einzige Datei, dieses NIP, wie hieß das noch gleich?
Dieses Default-NIP oder dieses große NIP-File, das ist jetzt unter Snow Leopard kleiner geworden. Also man kann nicht mehr so als Developer reingucken, so wie vorher, sondern sind nur noch die Essential-Sachen da.
Also die Bundles werden eh kleiner, aber das ist nicht das, worauf sich diese Meldung mit dem HFS Plus-Compression bezog. Und für mich las sich das schon so, als wäre hier wirklich von einer HFS Plus-Compression die Rede. Ich frage mich nur, wie sie das rückwärtskompatibel machen.
Na, da gibt es ja Möglichkeiten. So wie sie es mit 10.3 haben sie ja auch bei 10.3.9 den Universary...
Wie heißt das?
Uni... Na, das hier, das ist unter Intel und PowerPC läuft.
Universal Binary.
Genau, das haben sie erst mit 10.3.9 eingeführt. Und unter 10.3.8 gibt es das ja nicht. Das heißt, die könnten jetzt auch dieses HFS-Plus mit Compression für 10.4... Welche Version gibt es da gerade?
11 oder so? Achso, du meinst, dass sie...
Dass sie jetzt einen 10.4.12 rausbringen könnten. Damit funktioniert das und dann müssen alle die Tiger haben auf 10.4.12 gehen.
Das kann gut sein.
So mit Universal Binary haben sie das nämlich genau so gemacht.
Das kann gut sein. Ich wüsste nicht, wie sie das sonst drehen können.
Oder Alternative, dass einfach irgendwo ein zusätzliches Bit gesetzt wird und das dein Teil in Zukunft sagt, die Datei kann ich leider nicht öffnen, weil sie ist komprimiert.
Nein, das ist nicht das, was Rückwärtskompatibilität heißt.
Es ging ja darum, dass die Datei nicht zerstört werden.
Also du willst halt nach wie vor darauf zugreifen können. Das kannst du da nicht zugreifen, wenn da eine Fehlermeldung kommt, die sagt, du kannst nicht darauf zugreifen. Also das passt irgendwie alles hinten und vorne nicht. Dann gab ich...
Aber wofür überhaupt?
Na, weniger Platz. Na, du kannst da richtig viel...
Aber warum sind die da so geil drauf eigentlich? Kommt demnächst doch so ein Mini-Device?
Na, MacBook Air. Oder vielleicht...
Das ist nicht Mini.
Eine 80 GB Festplatte. Na, jetzt sind es 120, aber das ist nicht viel. Na, im Vergleich zu einem MacBook ist das irgendwie ein Drittel oder eine Hälfte.
Ja, aber wie viel können sie denn von ihrem System einsparen? Zehn Gig höchstens oder so? Oder fünf?
Das ist auf einem MacBook Air mit 80 GB ist das echt viel.
Na, wie viel ist denn so eine Grundinstallation ohne jetzt die ganzen extra Programme?
Das ist über zehn Prozent, was du dann einsparen würdest. Das ist viel.
Ob Apple dafür so einen riesen Alarm macht, wo man von absehen kann, dass das MacBook Air was in einem Jahr rauskommt, wahrscheinlich 256 GB SSD. Deswegen frage ich, wofür machen die das? Genau, die machen das nämlich fürs iPhone und vielleicht für noch so eine Zwischengröße.
Na ja, aber wie gesagt, ich behaupte mal, für das geheime Gerät, dieses geheime Gerät, das jetzt angeblich rumging, diese Zwischengröße zwischen iPhone und MacBook.
Ja, da gibt es schon noch eine Lücke zu schließen.
Was irgendein Suchmaschinenbetreiber entdeckt haben sollte?
Netbooks, was 501 Dollar kostet.
Weil unter 500 kriegen wir es ja nicht hin, ohne so scheiße.
Ne, für 500 wissen sie nicht, wie sie ein gutes bauen sollten.
Aber für 501 Dollar...
501, ich muss schon grinsen, weil so ein Mac Mini kostet 599, aber es ist auch kein Netbook.
Aber SSD auf jeden Fall, die könnten auch gut Kompressionen gebrauchen.
Genau, ich meine, wenn man jetzt nochmal so ein MacBook Air in einer Lite-Version hat. Ja, so ein MacBook Air, keine Ahnung, was ist denn noch eine Erträgliche Größe?
MacBook Vacuum. Oder, dass der Raum sich nach innen kriegt. Ne, mal ehrlich, was wäre ein denkbares Netbook-Format? Na alle wollen doch hier so ein 11 Zoll Shit haben, oder?
Also was ich hier an Urlaub ganz schick fand... Ich glaub nicht, dass sie unter diese Tastatur... Machen die nicht.
Du meinst so ein iPhone in groß? Ich weiß nicht.
Stell dir mal vor, du legst das Ding so hin. Das würdest du nicht. Und tippst so.
Das kaufst du doch nicht.
Nee, ich sowieso nicht.
Naja, aber wenn du das nicht kaufst, Dennis...
Ich kaufe mir auch kein MacBook.
Und kein Mini und kein iPhone.
Ja, wir sind nicht der Maßstab. Aber ich glaube es trotzdem nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Aber wer weiß.
Also Dünner als MacBook Air geht es jetzt bald wirklich nicht mehr.
Auf jeden Fall Platz sparen macht Sinn. Das macht auch Sinn auf dem iPhone.
Aber warum sollten die jetzt noch an ihrem HFS rumdrehen mit HFS Plus, wenn demnächst sowieso ZFS kommt mit Compression und so weiter und so fort?
Na, weil das ZFS zwar bei Snowlio dabei sein wird, aber es ist noch nicht das Fallsystem und das wird auch noch eine Weile dauern.
Na, wie viel wird es dann noch dauern? 2, 3 Jahre?
10, 7.
Für die Folter.
Ja, 10, 7 kann auf jeden Fall noch mal zwei Jahre dauern.
Ja, 2011.
Aber sie haben unter Umständen jetzt schon Produkte, wo sie gerne noch mal 10 Prozent der Speicher sparen würden. Ich meine, wie groß ist denn dein System-Ordner? Gucken wir doch mal unsere System-Ordner an.
Oh, Schwanzlängen, da gleich.
Das muss man erstmal wieder rauskriegen hier. Das wäre übrigens mal ein Feature, was in dieses US einbauen könnte. Ich habe überhaupt schon mal darüber abgeratet, wie unglaublich bekloppt dieser Finder ist. Ich bin ja manchmal schon selber...
Du fängst selber an, schon nachzurechnen, nachzuzählen, wie groß die Finder sind?
Ja, ich kann das selber schneller addieren als er. Also, das kennst du nicht, diesen Effekt. Du hast so einen Ordner, da sind zwei andere Ordner drin. Da steht drin, der eine Ordner ist so groß, der andere Ordner ist so groß, aber er ist nicht in der Lage, die Summe zu bilden da drauf.
Ich finde den umgekehrten Fall eigentlich noch viel spannender, wenn man sagt, ich will von dem äußeren Ordner, lasse ich mir die Größe ausrechnen, habe sie mir ausrechnen lassen, wo er eindeutig beide Ordner Größen berechnen muss.
Und er zeigt dann drinnen nichts an.
Und er zeigt dann drinnen, fängt er dann an so, ich glaube, da muss ich jetzt nochmal nachzählen, wie viel das jetzt eigentlich waren.
Das ist sowas von bekloppt.
Ja, total.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was sie da falsch machen, aber sie machen, glaube ich, alles falsch, was man sich nur irgendwie vorstellen kann.
Also, meiner ist 3,83.
Gut, das ist der System Ordner. Dann gibt es natürlich noch den Library Ordner von vornherein.
3,83 Gigabyte oder was?
Genau. Ja, aber das ist jetzt kein Vergleich, weil es sind ja beim, das ist ja nicht nur, wenn man so ein Betriebssystem frisch installiert, dann hat man erstmal noch einen Library Ordner auf jeden Fall, also auf der obersten Ebene, in dem auch schon mal ein bisschen was drinnen liegt, zum Beispiel diesen ganzen Garage Band Loops, die allein, glaube ich, mit zweieinhalb Gigabyte oder sowas rein knallen. Dann hast du es gelöscht. Ursprünglich hattest du es noch drauf.
Ich hab neu installiert natürlich. Wie war es letztens mit deinen Beleidigungen? Seitdem hab ich dich übrigens aus dem Twitter rausgekriegt. Das ging gar nicht. Deine Beleidigung 2.0? Du hast nicht neu installiert?
Wir haben so auf Twitter so eine kleine, lustige Aktion gestartet. Beleidigung 2.0, sowas wie du kommentierst bei YouTube.
Er hat bestimmt irgendwie so zehn Twitter die Minute gehabt oder so.
Ja, das war ganz aufregend.
Ich dachte gerade davon, jetzt reicht's, klick!
Ja, dann hab ich ge-unfollowed. Das hab ich mitbekommen.
War ich dich der Einzige bestimmt, oder?
Doch. Ansonsten hab ich dadurch nur gewonnen, klar.
Hast du ja schon gut Einzigen geteilt.
Das war ganz großartig. Das war an diesem Barcamp-Wochenende. Am letzten Wochenende war in Berlin ein Barcamp. Das war mein allerschönstes Barcamp in einer Telekom Hauptstadtzentrale mit viel Bremmbamborium, abends mit Partys, wo alle Getränke frei waren. Und das war schon sehr, sehr schick. Und dann waren wir, war die zweite Party, war, wie sich das gehört, stand es gemäß dem Oberholz. Und das Oberholz war voll mit Menschen, die alle ausschließlich an ihren Handys rumhackten und bei Twitter-Belleidigungen 2.0 reingehängt haben. Das war großartig. Und ich und der MS-Pro, wir haben es erfunden. Wow. Wir sind so stolz auf uns.
Ihr seid solche Trendsetter. Unglaublich.
Unglaublich.
Ja, derweil ist mein OS immer noch nicht in der Lage, auszurechnen, wie groß diese Dateien sind. Guckt euch mal dieses Elend hier an.
Da gehört ja auch noch der Application dazu.
Hier seht ihr einfach genau das, was ich gerade beschrieben habe. Also hier zeigt ihr mir an, die Datei ist 0 KB groß. Aber mir darüber zu sagen, wie groß der Ordner ist, in dem sich diese 0 KB-Datei befindet, das kriegt ihr irgendwie nicht auf die Reihe. Jetzt kommt da wieder mal ein paar Sachen hinterher. Ah, und jetzt kann er mir hier auch sagen, dass dieser Ordner, der Library, ist 3,88 GB groß.
Also System Library.
Nee, System muss er noch ausrechnen. Da ist zwar nur dieser Library-Ordner drin, aber da muss er jetzt erstmal nochmal drüber nachdenken.
Ja, das dauert halt seine Zeit. Ja, das ist wirklich ganz furchtbar. Ja, ich weiß ich doch nicht.
Mann, das ist wirklich eine Beleidigung. Ja, von ich und Fanboy, ihr habt ja eine Meise. Furchtbar ist das. Ich meine, das ist eine Beleidigung. Mit sowas läuft man rum. Dann kommt irgendein Mensch und schreibt in die Kommentare, dein Computer kann ja noch nicht mal Ordner ausrechnen.
Wär doch keiner, es dauert bloß einen Moment.
Ja, und? Was ist dann mit Tim? Der macht das auch falsch.
Er macht auch falsch?
Ja, das hab ich auch schon gehabt. Das haben wir falsche Sachen anzeigt. Der kann nicht rechnen. Und dann? Dann schlaf ich schlecht.
Du schläfst schlecht, weil dein Finder falsch rechnet?
Na, wenn ich weiß, dass mein Computer nicht funktioniert, dann schlaf ich schlecht.
Wobei, das ist ja auch schwer, oder?
Wie würdest du denn schlafen, wenn dein Computer falsch funktioniert?
Also, ich meine, spätestens wenn es darum geht, so mit Hardlinks, dass eine Datei zweimal ins Dateisystem eingehängt wird, dann ist es ja auch mal richtig schwer, richtig zu rechnen, oder? Dann hat man nämlich, nehmen wir mal an, du hast zwei Ordner, in denen zweimal die gleiche Datei per Hardlink drinne ist, die sagen wir mal 10 GB groß. Die liegt nur einmal auf deiner Festplatte drauf. Er muss aber anzeigen, der eine Ordner ist 10 GB groß, der andere Ordner ist auch 10 GB groß. Stimmt ja, aber trotzdem belegen beide Ordner zusammen auf deiner Festplatte nur 10 GB. Magic. Oder ist es gar nicht so leicht, so richtig zu rechnen, wie groß die Ordner sind und wie viel Platz frei ist und wie viel belegt ist?
Das stimmt, wobei ich mir noch nicht mal sicher bin, ob das überhaupt richtig macht, wenn das dann so ist.
Das hab ich auch noch nicht nachgerechnet.
Das müsste man dann nochmal ausprobieren. Trotzdem, also auf einem System, wo er in der Lage ist, trotz 20.000 anwesender Dateien oder mehr, jederzeit mir für das nächste Spotlight-Backup zu sagen, welche Datei sich geändert hat, da muss er auch in der Lage sein, sich in dem Moment dann auch mal kurz zu merken, wie groß diese Datei ist. Muss auch in der Lage sein, zu merken, ob vielleicht das ein Link auf eine Datei ist, die er schon gezählt hat. Das geht einfach.
Aber sagen wir so, ich kenne da konkurrierende Betriebssysteme, wo Programme während sie...
Der rechnet immer noch.
Wenn die anfangen, sich zu installieren, erst mal ausrechnen, ob überhaupt noch genügend Platz auf der Platte frei ist für dieses Programm. Und das...
Es geht alles überhaupt nicht.
Dass andere Betriebssysteme offensichtlich nicht mehr ein bisschen Platz, die noch zur Verfügung kamen, das finde ich eigentlich noch viel skandalöser.
Da, hier ist der andere Fall. Jetzt weiß ich, dass der Frameworks-Ordner 1,58 Gigabyte groß ist, aber er kann mir für keinen der Ordner da drin sagen, wie groß sie sind. Geht's noch? Leute, wir müssen mit diesem Podcast ein Ende finden. Ja, weil erstens, dauert der schon.
Haben wir denn schon alles?
Nee, ich hab schon noch, äh, ich hab noch was. Also bei Apples Umweltinitiative reden wir nicht, oder? Das ist zu langweilig.
Doch, ist jetzt grüner geworden. In die Preferenz ist jetzt keine Glühlampe mehr, sondern eine CFL, eine...
Eine Energiespar-Lampe, das find ich auch total knuffig.
Sieht furchtbar eklig aus.
Ja, so eine komische Wende...
Sieht aus wie so eine Klobürste. Oder so ein Turd.
Ein Light Turd.
Findest du lustig? Ich will nicht so einen komischen... einen Wurst da haben. So eine Lichtwurst.
Das ist genauso wie bei diesen unbeschränkten Bahnübergangsschildern, wo dann irgendwann mal keine Eisenbahn mehr durchgerollt ist, sondern so ein Dampflokomotiv, sondern ICE.
Ja, aber ein ICE sieht ja noch halbwegs schnittig aus, weil diese Lichtwurst...
Ja, aber du wirst auch niemals einen ICE auf einem unbeschränkten Bahnübergang sehen.
Das stimmt. Wie auch immer, es gibt noch eine News. Ich weiß bloß nicht genau, wie neu das ist, aber ihr habt es ja sicherlich auch mitbekommen. Piffige Jungs, wie ihr seid. Es gibt da einen Artikel auf Apple Developer Connection, also auf ihrer Entwickler-Webseite, und dort stellen sie ein System vor, das heißt McRuby. Ach ja, wie lange gibt es denn das schon?
McRuby gibt es schon länger, aber jetzt gefeatured wird es erst seit diesem Artikel da offiziell.
Ja, und seit wann gibt es diesen Artikel? Hier steht nämlich kein Datum dabei.
In zwei Wochen oder so?
Oder doch, hier, 17.10. steht dabei, ganz unten steht es. Da finde ich ein paar Sachen ganz bemerkenswert. Also erstens heißt das, wenn ich das richtig übersetze, man kann jetzt in Ruby vollwertige Coco-Applikationen machen, ohne Einschränkung. Richtig, falsch?
Ich mach keine Ruby.
Also ich hab mich das letzte Mal mit dem Thema beschäftigt, das war zu, als 10.05. noch in Beta war. Und da ist mir damals schon aufgefallen, dass Xcode eine erschreckend große, eine sehr große Ruby-Unterstützung hatte, was die IDE anging. Und dass schon einige Beispiele beigelegt worden sind, wie man in Ruby auf das Coco-Framework und diese ganzen Frameworks zugreifen kann. Insofern wundert mich das ein bisschen gerade, also ich bin da auch darüber gestolpert über das Thema und hab's dann erst mal so, naja, ist ja ein alter Hut und hab's zur Seite gelegt. Was da jetzt neu ist, das weiß ich auch nicht.
Na, es gibt einen neuen Aspekt und der neue Aspekt ist der, dass sie einen eigenen Ruby-Interpreter beigetragen haben. Das heißt, es handelt sich um eine eigene Ruby-Implementierung. Sie nehmen nicht einfach das Ruby, in Usab in Ruby und dann kannst du daraus irgendwas machen. Sondern du schreibst deinen Ruby, was auf einer eigenen Randheim läuft, in der alle Kernobjekte wie Strings und so weiter, also der Ruby-Sprache deines Ruby-Environments, tatsächlich Core Foundation-Objekte sind. Das heißt, wenn du so einen String hast, dann ist es halt ein CF-String und so weiter. Und das heißt, du arbeitest quasi in Ruby genauso mit den Objekten, wie du das in Objective-C machst.
Das ist der beste Weg, um endlich Real Basic zu kennen.
Naja, das ist auf jeden Fall. Und ich meine, warum sie dann Ruby nehmen, verwundert mich insofern nicht. Das schreiben sie ja auch, dass einfach syntaktisch sind die auch so weit nicht auseinander. Weil das hat sich ja auch sehr viel bei Smalltalk abgeschaut. Du hast da weitgehend ein identisches Objekt-Modell. Und es handelt sich natürlich um eine extrem populäre Sprache. Und ich frage mich natürlich jetzt, wenn sie einen eigenen Interpreter machen. Haben sie jetzt nur den normalen Ruby-Interpreter genommen und ein bisschen aufgebohrt? Oder haben sie jetzt wirklich einen eigenen geschrieben? Und was exekutiert das dann? Und kommt hier vielleicht LLVM zum Einsatz?
Und wann läuft das auf dem iPhone?
Ja, Ruby nicht. Hätten wir das schon gelesen. Aber in ein paar Tagen kommt die neue LLVM-Version raus. 2.4, dann können wir ja wissen wir mehr.
Wenn da drin steht mit Ruby-Support, kriege ich aber ein Bienchen, oder?
Aber das ist relativ public bei denen. Das hätten wir schon rausgefunden.
Ja, ich glaube auch nicht, dass es unbedingt das sein muss. Trotzdem sind sie da dran. Und auf mich macht das so den Eindruck, als ob sie das extrem ernst meinen. Also als ob sie wirklich...
Aber es ist doch interessant, wieso Java schmeißen sie raus so?
Java ist halt nicht dynamisch. Und Ruby ist dynamisch. Na, Dynamic Binding. Das war halt... Java ist eine weitgehend statische Sprache. Eine Variable hat dann halt irgendwie seinen Typ und den hat sie dann auch, den behält sie dann auch. Und viele Entscheidungen werden halt zu Compile Time gemacht. In einer dynamischen Programmiersprache kann sich auf vieles beziehen. Vor allem assoziiert man damit halt, dass Dynamic Binding, kann halt der Typ einer Variable sich am laufenden Meter auch ändern. Also deine Referenz auf irgendetwas kann halt jetzt mal ein String und später ein Staubsauger sein. Und Robi ist halt eine voll dynamische Sprache, wie das eben die meisten, oder was auch immer. Robi, wie die meisten Scriptsprachen, legt ja halt relativ wenig Fesseln auf. Und das macht halt das Programmieren einfacher. Mit diesem klassischen Nachteilsargument, dann ist das ja auch langsam. Dass das aber nicht mehr so sein muss, sehen wir jetzt wunderbar gerade in dieser Entwicklung der JavaScript-Engines, die wir erstaunend beobachten, die immer schneller werden. Bei Chrome mit V8, bei WebKit mit dem SquirrelFish und auch Firefox hat ja eine beschleunigte JavaScript-Engine in Arbeit. Und die arbeiten am Ende alle mit demselben Methoden. Hier geht es um Bytecode, Native-Kompilierung zur Laufzeit und so weiter. Dass also wirklich Scriptsprachen genommen werden, die ja nur deshalb so heißen, weil sie eben in der Regel klassisch immer zur Laufzeit interpretiert wurden. Tatsächlich aber vollwertige Programmiersprachen sind und die theoretisch auch compiled werden könnten, es bloß nie wurden. Und jetzt eben zur Laufzeit so schnell in Bytecode übersetzt werden, dass sie eben auch mithalten können. Zumal jetzt bei so einer Anwendung auf Mac sehr viel eben auch vom Betriebssystem getragen wird. Also das ganze GUI und so weiter, und Maus und Events und Schnickes und so weiter. Viel macht sowieso das.
In teuren Operationen macht eigentlich das so SR Genau, so.
Und dann kannst du eben das Ganze auch noch mit Ruby machen. Und wenn sie es auch noch schaffen, dann die Randheim wirklich fix zu machen. Also nicht nur mit ihrem Kram zu integrieren, wie sie es offensichtlich jetzt getan haben, also mit ihren Con Foundation Classes, sondern wenn sie dem auch noch mit LLVM ein richtig speedy Environment gönnen, dann sage ich nur Spitze, dann haben sie ein Problem gelöst.
Vor allem nicht nur das. Es geht ja auch darum, dass man, also bei dieser bisherigen Ruby-Implementierung, das war ja schon, also da haben sie sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben, das möglichst gut ins Betriebssystem zu integrieren, dass man also in Ruby echte Programme schreiben konnte. Aber eben der String war ein Ruby-String und wenn du ein NS-String hattest, dann musstest du immerhin und her konvertieren und weißt ja toll was und musstest es entsprechend casten. Das war dann weder die Eleganz von dem einen noch die Eleganz von dem anderen. Und damit kriegen sie es vielleicht, wenn ich das richtig sehe, so auf Anhieb vielleicht ein bisschen besser hin.
Also ich finde das auf jeden Fall sehr interessant.
Und ähnliches gibt es für Python auch.
Es gibt da einen Blog sogar dafür, McRuby. Und McRuby ist auch auf MacOS Forge, wo so viele andere tolle Sachen sind, wie zum Beispiel WebKit und so. Ja, also alle anderen Themen auf meiner Liste vertage ich. Ich will jetzt nicht mehr darüber reden.
Aber auf jeden Fall freue ich mich nochmal ganz kurz.
Oder? Sollen wir noch über die Web 2.0 Expo reden?
Das können wir beim nächsten Mal machen, oder?
Na dann ist ja alter Hut. Warst du da?
Nee, ich war nur auf der einen Partie, bin ich mit hingeschleift worden.
Ja ich hab mir, ach das muss ich jetzt noch erzählen, ich hatte nicht viel Zeit daran teilzunehmen, aber ich hab mir dann einen Vortrag von Nokia angeschaut. Die hatten so ein paar Finder hingeladen und die haben ein Workshop gemacht. Und das Thema war S60 Widgets offiziell. Und das war wirklich absurd. Also der Slot war irgendwie drei Stunden und ich sag gleich...
Was ist denn S60 Widget ungefähr?
Na S60 ist diese...
Das Betriebssystem von Nokia, Symbian.
Na es ist die Plattform. Die S60 Plattform. Es gibt die S30 Plattform und die S60.
Und es gibt auch noch andere.
Das ist Symbian, genau. Du erinnerst dich hier noch an mein Artikel E61 und so. Das ist so diese Kategorie.
Und seitdem du dein iPhone hast, hast du die wieder angefasst, wa?
Da liegt's. Hier. Hab ich noch nicht einmal wieder eingeschaltet. Das ist die S60. Na wie auch immer. Ich war einfach nur mal gespannt, was sie sozusagen anbieten. Was sie sozusagen dem Developer anbieten. Und es war... Es war wirklich unterirdisch. Erstmal stellten sie sich da hin und er hat irgendwie eine dreiviertel Stunde lang über Nokia und über ihr Smartphone-Business geredet. Und es hat wirklich eine dreiviertel Stunde gedauert, bis überhaupt das Thema Widgets das erste Mal fiel. Und sie haben halt alles Mögliche erzählt, wie man denn so entwickeln könnte. Und es war wirklich der bunte Tüte ladendeluxe. Nach dem Motto, wir können irgendwie alles und nichts. Kannst ja irgendwie in Silverlight und in Flash oder in Java und in C++ und in C kannst du entwickeln. Und dann halt eben auch im Web. Das waren dann halt sozusagen die Widgets. Die ganze Zeit eigentlich drauf gewartet hatte, was sie mir da sozusagen erzählen können, dass ich mir dachte, vielleicht kann man da ja mal schnell eine Applikation drauf werfen und dann sieht das irgendwie gut aus. Ja, dann waren das so Finnen, die dann auch immer wieder betonten, dass sie die Wahrheit dann später erzählen würden, wenn man ihnen ein Bier ausgibt. Bei bestimmten Wahrheiten warfe dann zwischendurch ein, müssten es dann auch schon drei sein. Da kam ich schon so langsam ins Grübeln. Sie waren eigentlich ganz lustig und sie versuchten auch wirklich irgendwie zu connecten. Aber die kamen mir total paralysiert vor, die Jungs. Meinte sie so, ja, man kann ja bei uns auch entwickeln. Und meinte dann so, na ja, das iPhone wäre ja ein tolles Gerät und das würde ja auch wirklich Spaß machen, dafür zu entwickeln. Der Nokia-Mitarbeiter. Aber so schlecht wär's bei ihnen ja auch nicht. Und der App Store vom iPhone, der wär ja ganz super.
Sowas hätten wir auch gerne.
Daran würden sie arbeiten. Das, was sie gerade hätten, wär nicht so toll, aber da würde vielleicht noch was kommen. Und so ging das die ganze Zeit. Dann auch so mit dem Browser. Ja, wir haben ja auch einen Webbrowser auf unserer S60-Plattform. Er würde lieber den Browser auf seinem iPod Touch benutzen, aber der würde schon auch funktionieren.
Welche Wahrheit ist das? Kommt danach der Bier noch?
Keine Ahnung. Ich hab mir die Zeit dann nicht genommen. Nach dieser ersten dreiviertel Stunde Einführung, mit was man theoretisch alles entwickeln könnte, ohne eine klare Empfehlung, was denn jetzt vielleicht mal der Weg wäre. Es war so ein bisschen gemischt waren, man könnte ja irgendwie alles machen, aber dann auch irgendwie nicht, weil du natürlich auf keiner Plattform alles machen kannst. Manche Sachen kannst du natürlich nur in der Plattform machen und so weiter. Und wir wissen ja auch, wie gut das läuft mit dem Flash und dem Java und so weiter. Und ich sag's da einfach, war vollkommen konsterniert, dass er einfach die ganze Zeit das iPhone und seinen iPod Touch gelobt hat, während er versucht hat, Leute dafür zu begeistern, für Nokia zu entwickeln.
Und dabei gibt's auf dem iPhone noch nicht mal widgets.
Und ehrlich, ich übertreib jetzt nicht. Der hat das wirklich wortwörtlich genauso gesagt, wie es jetzt hier von mir gegeben haben. Natürlich auf Englisch. Und naja, dann dachte ich mir so, mal gucken. Dann wollte er eine Demo zeigen, wie man ein Widget dann eben programmiert. Es handelte sich um ein Hello World Widget, in dem man eine Texteingabezeile hat, wo man noch ein Wort eingeben kann. Wenn man Return drückt, dann sagt er wahrscheinlich Hello, was auch immer du eingegeben hast. Dazu hat er dann so eine, wie heißt das noch gleich, diese Open Source IDE für so... Nee, Abtera oder so?
Aptana.
Aptana, genau.
Aptana ist basiert auf Eclipse.
Genau. Basiert auf Eclipse, geht auch irgendwie stand alone, aber integriert sich gut, wie auch immer, damit hat er das dann irgendwie gemacht. Ja, dann hat er aber dann auch so seine Issues damit gehabt und kam dann irgendwie zwischendurch nicht vorwärts und dann ging wieder irgendwas nicht. Meinte nur zu seinem Kollegen so, jetzt weiß ich, was du meintest mit, man sollte nicht immer die neueste Version für Präsentationen nehmen und so. Dann ging das irgendwie hin und her, da versucht er dann irgendwie zu fixen, hat das wieder andersrum gemacht. Am Ende ist er dann daran gescheitert, dass sein Syncing Tool mit seinem Telefon nicht funktionierte und er nicht in der Lage war, dieses Widget auch tatsächlich aufs Telefon zu bringen. Und hat es dann in einem Emulator gezeigt.
Aber da hat es immerhin funktioniert.
Nach einer halben Stunde, ein Hello World HTML Widget mit etwas JavaScript drin. Und ich dachte mir nur so, wobei sagen wir mal so, you are fucking doomed und ich muss mir jetzt unbedingt Apple-Aktien kaufen.
Das will ich gerade.
Aber da muss man ja mal sagen, sein Programm, was man auf Xcode entwickelt hat, auf Mac, das dann auch nachher tatsächlich auf iPhone zu kriegen, das ist ja auch nicht gerade der aller einfachste Weg, wenn man nicht gerade ein jailbroken iPhone hat. Oh, das ist auch so, bis man das Gerät mal freigeschaltet hat und bis man überall eingegeben hat, dass man die entsprechenden Signaturen hochgeladen und runtergeladen kann.
Na ja, das ist vielleicht umständlich, aber nicht unmöglich. Aber zumindest funktioniert es dann am Ende. Es ist nur eine Frage der Signaturen und dieses ganzen Prozesse.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das auch nur manchmal funktioniert.
Na ja, ich glaube mit der Digital Keychain in anderen Systemen, da hast du ganz anders zu kämpfen.
Aber da kann ich auch nochmal kurz, ich probier's kurz zu machen, vom Barcamp war ich auf einem Panel von einer Telekom und das hieß, hat den schönen Namen, Making the Elephant Dance. Also so, den Elefanten doch mal zum Tanzen bringen. Dann haben sie erstmal erklärt, warum das bei der Telekom alles ganz furchtbar kompliziert ist, weil das eine große Firma ist.
Was meinen sie denn damit, mit Making the Elephant Dance?
Die wollen unmögliche möglich machen.
Die wollen APIs, um sich zu öffnen, um für die Web2.0 Community interessanter zu sein und um ihre Schnittstellen, die sie haben, zu öffnen. Das sind ein paar relativ engagierte Leute innerhalb der Telekom, die das ein bisschen forcieren. Das machen sie auch schon eine ganze Weile.
Was wollen sie denn da öffnen?
Es gibt bisher genau drei Schnittstellen. Einmal, dass du SMS-Nachrichten verschicken kannst über eine Web-AP. Was ganz spannend ist, wenn man als Developer pro Tag 100 frei SMS kriegt, was ich schonmal ganz ordentlich finde. Dann, dass man sogenannte Third-Party-Calls initiieren kann. Das heißt also, dass man über eine Web-AP eingibt die und die Telefonnummer und die Telefonnummer, die möchte ich jetzt gern verbunden haben miteinander. Und dass es dann auf beiden Seiten klingelt und dadurch dann ein Gespräch hergestellt wird, was man dann ein bisschen steuern kann. Und was war die dritte AP? Die dritte AP habe ich jetzt vergessen. Und das wollen sie jetzt langsam so ein bisschen in die Wege leiten. Das haben sie dann schön, erstmal langer Vortrag darum, warum das alles so ganz kompliziert ist und warum das alles nicht so geht. Und warum sie auch intern Widerstände haben. Und dann irgendwann haben sie probiert, jetzt zeigen wir mal, wie dieser tolle AP funktioniert. Und wir stellen jetzt ein Telefonat her. Wir haben hier ein echtes Telefon. Und weil wir beweisen wollen, dass wir wirklich Telefonate initiieren können und das jetzt nicht einfach gefakt ist, liebe Telekom, kann uns jemand aus dem Publikum seine Telefonnummer ansagen. Und dann hört sich irgendeine Person bereit, erklärt die Telefonnummer an zu sagen, ist die jetzt auch sicher, ist die Datenschutz technisch sicher? Ja, ja, ruf sie mal einmal laut durch den Raum, was er dann auch gemacht hat. Dann wurde die laut durch den Raum aufgezogen. Es klappte natürlich nicht mit der Third-Party-Call-Initiierung. Kann ja nicht jedes Telefonat klappen bei so einem Verein wie der Telekom.
Das geht wahrscheinlich einfach nicht mit jeder Nummer.
Das geht wahrscheinlich einfach nicht mit jeder Nummer. Ich glaube, es war sogar ein Thema, egal. Und dann hatte ich auf jeden Fall probiert, mich dann für so einen Entwickler-Account anzumelden. Und das hat mich ungelogen, vier Tage gekostet, mir so einen dämlichen Account zu besorgen. Ich wollte es noch direkt während des Panels machen, da war der Anmeldungs-Server down. Wenn dann der Anmeldungs-Server down war, dann musste man sich noch einen zweiten, dann war der irgendwann wieder da, dann musste man sich noch irgendwo einen zweiten Account besorgen, dann musste man die beiden Accounts miteinander verbinden. Dann hat er ihm von irgendwo her der Chef von irgendeiner Firma eine Mail geschickt. Du, wir haben dich jetzt händisch down da eingetragen. Das war nicht, das war nicht, das war der geplante Ablauf. Es gab eine zweiseitige Anleitung, was man machen muss, um sich zum blöden Account zuzulegen. Ich hab's dann an dem Punkt aufgegeben, als ich dann zwar offiziell Zugriff auf alles habe, aber dann gesagt habe, hey, ihr habt da irgendwas von Code-Beispielen genannt, an dem man sich das Ganze mal angucken kann. Wo kann ich jetzt die Code-Beispiele herbekommen? Es gab natürlich keine Kontaktadresse. Das hab ich dann per Twitter gemacht und wurden mir gesagt, das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Ich leite das mal an die entsprechende Stelle weiter.
Also nichts, was man jetzt nicht auch erwarten würde.
Und seitdem hab ich nichts mehr von ihm gehört. Das ist, ich hab wirklich noch nie so lange gebraucht, um Account besorgen, Dokumentation durchlesen, Beispielcode implementieren. Ich hab's bis jetzt nicht gemacht.
Aber wir sind jetzt passend beim Thema. Aber eins hab ich auch noch ganz klein. Und zwar ist ja der Tech-Talk für iPhone-Programmierung am 10. November in Berlin. Ich hab mir auch schon angemeldet. Ich glaub, du auch, ne Tim?
Ja, aber ich hab keine Bestätigung bekommen.
Ich hab auch noch keine Bestätigung bekommen. Aber ich hab auch gehört, dass ganz viele unserer Hörer, also einige, auch dort sein werden.
Du meinst, sie haben auch keine Bestätigung bekommen?
Nee, bisher fragen sie immer im Twitter alle. Weil in München war der Talk wohl schon.
Ja, das war wohl auch scheiße.
Das hab ich noch nicht gehört.
Marketing, bla bla.
Ja, klar.
Aber auch nicht nur, oder?
Ich hab auch noch nie was anderes von Apple in Deutschland gesehen. Also alle diese Developer, sogenannten Developer-Veranstaltungen, die ich bisher beibruhte.
Du hast das halt immer relativ oberflächlich halt. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass irgendwelche Uppie-Calls und Methoden erklären.
Warum nennen sie das denn Tech-Talk?
Weil sie einen so einführen und sagen, was so geht. So reinlesen musst du dich dann schon selber.
Ja gut, aber meistens sind das die Informationen, die dir eben verpasst. Wie auch immer. Und du willst da hin und willst dich mit allen Hörern treffen?
Nee, ich geh mit Sonnenbrille.
Okay, der Typ mit Sonnenbrille.
Scheiße, möchte um Himmels Willen nicht erkannt werden.
Ja, ich muss irgendwie in Cognito gehen. Und du willst da nicht hin, oder wie?
Doch. Also, wenn ich da...
Es ist einfach keine Sonnenbrille auf dich.
Die Frage ist, wenn man nicht bestätigt wird, geht man dann trotzdem hin?
Klar.
Ja, ich glaube, am Ende schicken die auch keinen weg.
Solange Platz ist.
Ja, das ist dann auch... Wo ist denn das? In der Uni?
Nee, in irgendeinem Hotel. Wieder mit Essen und so.
Schick. Ach, echt?
Klar.
Sicher? In München war das in der Uni.
Ah, echt?
Bist du sicher, dass es im Hotel ist?
Nein, ich war schon mal bei irgendeinem anderen hier vor drei, vier Jahren mit Fokami und da haben sie über Tiger erzählt oder irgendwie so, gerade frisch neu. Und das war in irgendeinem Hotel in Neukölln. Das ist ein Hotel in Neukölln, da ist ein Sonderleder ganz hinten irgendwie, so an so einer Brücke, keine Ahnung.
Ach so, Estrell.
Ja, kann sein. Und da gab es auch irgendwie so Essen mit einem neuen, oder Schnittchen.
Na hoffen wir mal, dass es Schnittchen gibt, wenn es schon keine Informationen gibt.
Das ist ein Estrell-Hotel und schick, würde ich jetzt aber auch nicht in einem Satz sagen, oder?
Na für umsonst.
Anyway, sind wir durch? Wollen wir noch mutmaßen, ob der Mcmini stirbt oder nicht?
Stirbt?
Also es gibt ja zurzeit zwei Gerüchte, die so rumgehen. Eins, er wird sterben. Zweitens, er kriegt ein Chip-Sides-Update, was jetzt für mich relativ geht. Ich glaub, das andere wird jetzt erstirbt. Das ist, nein, er stirbt nicht und wird auferstehen. Das ist ja eigentlich noch die, ich glaube auch, den Bezweiflung.
Was heißt, er kriegt einen anderen Chip-Sides-Update? Also klar, irgendwann müssen sie mal ändern. So und dann sind sie ja gerade bei Nvidia dabei. Wieso nicht?
Ich glaub auch, dass sie den Mcmini nicht sterben lassen können. Und der wird jetzt auch sehr bald wahrscheinlich noch dieses Jahr aktualisiert, weil jetzt haben sie mit ihrem Mini-Display-Port angefangen. Und gerade für den Mini macht dieser neue Bildschirm total Sinn. Also ein Mini und dieser Bildschirm ist so eine coole Alternative, wobei da kann man sich auch gleich einen iMac kaufen. 24 Zoll iMac, was kostet der? Läuft doch das gleiche raus, ne?
Also ich weiß das.
Das sind Agenturen, die haben sehr, sehr gerne die Mac-Minis gekauft.
Das Problem ist bei dem iMac, da kann man nicht irgendwann mal sagen, ich hab hier so ein Bildschirm für dich, da ist noch ein Rechner drin, aber den musst du ja nicht benutzen, das geht nicht. Du kannst den iMac-Bildschirm nicht irgendwie für andere Geräte benutzen. Das ist das, was mich dann stören würde.
Auch der Mac Mini für Switcher gerade, die so sagen, ich hab hier einen PC rumstehen, aber ich hab ja zu viel von den tollen Macs gehört, stelle ich mir mal dazu, zum rasch umschalten, 500 Euro kann man schon mal machen. 600. Kann man mal so einen iMac nicht machen? Auch nicht, sondern da hat man gleich die große Kiste auf dem Tisch.
Ich hätte es schon auch gerne getrennt, weil ein Display hält länger eigentlich heutzutage als ein Computer, oder? Ein Computer hat so eine Lebenszeit von zwei, drei Jahren, so ein Display ist schon ein bisschen mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber man hört ja mal wieder, dass Steve Jobs den Mac Mini hassen soll.
Glaub ich nicht. An den Hassen würde er dahin nicht hergestellt.
Angeblich nur auf Druck der Anleger.
Wir können jetzt abschließend noch einen kleinen Witz erzählen. Und zwar haben wir uns vorhin überlegt, warum Windows so viel in Cloud Computing investiert. Und wir sind dann drauf gekommen, dass ihnen nichts bestes eingefallen ist, mit den ganzen Windows-Kisten jetzt rumstehen, weil die ganzen Switcher jetzt ja irgendwie noch ein Windows-Kiss dazu stehen haben. Und die könnte man ja für Cloud Computing einsetzen. Das sind ja Millionen. Ist ja wahrscheinlich dann von Null auf Platz Eins in der Supercluster-Computer-Ding. Wie heißt diese Liste?
Microsoft SETI. Wir suchen jetzt nach extraterrestrischer Intelligenz, weil wir haben selber bei uns nicht genug gefunden.
Oder der Kreditkartennummer von Steve Jobs, um denen ein bisschen an Geld ranzukommen.
Jungs, ich glaube unsere Performance geht nach unten. Wir müssen jetzt ganz schnell Schluss machen, oder?
Dennis hat einen Witz erzählt, wir müssen Schluss machen. Vorhin kam er spontan und da war es schon gut.
Ja, wir müssen ja alles immer...
Wir haben es nicht vorgestellt, wir sind total...
Doch, ich bin Dennis und ich bin links, hoffe ich.
Ja, du bist für Obama. Siehst du, wusste ich doch gleich.
Da habe ich gestern einen schönen Witz gehört. Ich habe einen Film gedreht über John McCain und der heißt No Country for Old Men.
Jetzt ist aber wirklich Schluss hier. Es ist wirklich Schluss. Ich könnte jetzt den anderen Witz nochmal erzählen.
Und ich war Tim und ich verhindere das. Dennis erzählt den anderen Witz, der echt schlecht war.